no doubt all right welcome to the last
word episode number 100 100 it's another
glorious Friday we're back from the
campfire for some more looters shooter
discussion I'm extremely excited about
our special guest so we gonna get right
into it I want to introduce a Lord who
is not only epitome of what it means to
be a law connoisseur but whose passion
for the destiny franchise is only
matched by his humility and extreme
attention to the subtleties of
storytelling
introducing the creating hosts of the my
name is by few to channel and founder of
the peasant guard destiny clan the Lord
with the smoothest yet most pragmatic
voice in all of YouTube and of course
everyone's favorite Warlock Lord Danny
to make his debut at the campfire of the
last word
mommy Lord my name is by fighty doing
sir
during wow that is probably the most
illustrious intro I've ever had like
you're doing really well like I'm very
glad to be on lost football here
especially for episode 100 holy Lord
that's that's fantastic
no pressure anything whatsoever
good man we are so happy to have you
here and I think you've Ike thank you
for breaking my chat by the way some of
you guys this is amazing
but no seriously like anybody who's been
involved in in this game for a little
while has been like hey what's this
about they know you so yes we couldn't
think of a better way to celebrate us
starting this podcast during curse of
Osiris an optimal time to have destiny
to to bring you in and celebrate making
it to this one so duh like huge tip of
the hat and thank you from across the
pond so no this is this is amazing so
absolutely thank you for having me on
yeah a pleasure a pleasure just need to
double down on what uh what he was
saying it's like yeah we started you
know we were initially uh
flashpoint at the time before we changed
your name and um you know we just the
thing came down to you know I met I
bought this when my first Guardian cons
we say 20 right right 2016 and then um
hit it off and I'm like me there's this
this guy loves destiny as much as I do
and we should say hey man you want to do
a podcast and the whole thing just came
from a labor of love at destiny at its
worst time by like it was cursed most
Irish the communities upset oh boy I
remember the dead games are going all
over and we're just sitting there the
the era of two tokens and a blue like
you think that like people think that
complaining about bounties the current
season is bad like I want everyone to
remember we've had worse look you know
those dark ties brothers so it was just
everyone's piling on and me and he's
like no we still love this game and what
can we talk about to fix it and so on
and so forth and then it just bubbled
forfeit here we are a hundred episodes
later it's still doing it but good to
have the Lord master in but you know we
got it we got to interview the law
masturbate this is a man of many talents
a lot of things going on with a man so
first off I got a some question you know
say so for me you know obviously it's
always good to have a fellow warlock but
it's red it's been a lot of titans that
come through a lot of hunters they cook
them we got a warlock here so my first
question for by fizz what made you
attracted to the class and second part
is who's your favorite warlock and
Destin oh well oh that's that second
one's a really tricky one to answer
um yeah reason to be attracted to the
clothes in the first place is because
previously whenever I was doing D&D and
stuff I'd always play something like say
a warrior or you know a paladin and I
you know I eventually branched out into
cleric because you know you can do the
whole tanking thing you can deal some
decent melee damage with a few like off
spec things and then also you know you
can
cos magic most crucially and ice at the
beginning of destiny I was like you know
what for once I'm gonna go pure
quote-unquote spellcaster and of course
that's not truly how destiny works but I
kind of fell into that kind of vibe of
being a warlock as it kind of went
forward and yeah really it really did
fit in the end especially considering
that I didn't actually stop by covering
the law and destiny I started as another
news channel who was just doing stuff
day by day and trying to get details out
there and you know trying to be ahead of
the curve on the hype and everything and
then you know I think it was taking king
I did what was my most considered like
my first true lore video which was a
video about the books of sorrow which
yeah amazing yeah that was that was the
starter series that are still not
finished and now with the current state
of the world it's totally on track as a
result yeah one did one day we'll get to
finishing that but now that's kind of
what drew me to work is it was a little
bit of something different and also I I
was kind of going into University at the
time being and I'd lofty ambitions and
lofty goals and you know I was
surrounded by this place of intellectual
rigor and I was like you know this makes
some sense I only fly and you know you
gotta try and like fit in with where you
are and fit in where are in your life
and for me at that moment I I thought
that that kind of appropriately did it
and I fall I fallen in love with it for
many other reasons by now but you know
it's it still left me in this place
where I live and breathe the class as
for the rest you gotta pick up amongst
your children you gotta pick a bunch of
kids who's your favorite child see I
mean so here's the thing like it sounds
like such a candle answer to say Osiris
cuz he's very powerful and I don't think
I'm gonna say that as a result I'm gonna
say Ariana you know she's strong war
look of the praxic order very powerful
wielder of solar light you know amazing
story one of the best exotics in the
game in area
his mouth was tied after her and also
harder the praxic fire it was like it
was the first decent warlock exotica
that I got and yeah it stuck with me
through literally the entirety of
Destiny one yeah like you know that's I
feel like I feel like I'm bound up in
that story now you know it ties in just
so many of the great elements of the
game you know I sent heiress Tyson to
crota ties into eventually Oryx you know
it Hawkins back to the city and all the
different guardian orders and all this
other stuff and it's just yeah
ariana is a kind of central calling
point to this all of it gasps oh yeah it
gotta be Arabella
I'm bias I'm leading the witness yes
[Laughter]
trying to knock brother Vance at a
convention for his latest video the
great deception Vance in the same light
anymore is this trickster oh boy Annika
in a couple of weeks when that trials
low book is completely attainable for
some people oh boy that's wait you're up
I'm starstruck I'm amazed no like for me
just when it's like when I've always dug
into this game it's like we started with
destiny one that had so many more
questions than answers especially when
we had our vanilla lunch and everything
and then you go through and then when it
comes to this type of game it's like
what what kind of compelled you to
almost take up plate the storytelling
role of this is there something that
just like this is how it's starting you
kind of developed into it or is it like
I know my voice is amazing so I'm going
to use it or
let him read me the McDonald's menu and
he's definitely like I won 5-2 right now
trying not to laugh over here but I
wanted to know like what got you into
knowing like just your ability to tell a
story how did you kind of come to that
realization that's that was just the
talent of yours well I didn't realize
that it was a talent up until like
obviously about six months ago was the
point which I had that moment where I
sat there and differently said to myself
this is not just a job I want to do
storytelling generally of some kind you
know I want to be the orator for a great
world and for a great story but the
first kind of point at which I really
decided like hey this is what I want to
jump in and talk about this is what I
want to do was when he back actually in
dark below I released my first video in
the taken King but in dark below I was
one of the people who was still hanging
on to destiny even though dark below was
unquestionably the worst content release
that we'd had like you know three story
missions two strikes if you're a
penetration and then the rate and then
you know a few things here and there it
was not it was a great time to be
playing destiny you know and it it was
kind of it was a very low point but i
sat there and I was like this gotta be
more in this you know like I refuse to
sit there and believe this thing that
I've seen growing for years now has only
got so much steam in it and doesn't have
a story I refuse that I like I like I
directly refuted that line of destiny
has no story which of the time-being was
the meme right yes like though there
would be things like you know oh destiny
you know talk about it's at least it
wasn't as bad a love story as twilight
oh wait no it was my kind of thing right
like people would meme on it like that
yes ice i sat there and i said no i'm
gonna go out there and I'm gonna find
this stuff and that was the point at
which I really really deeply started
pouring myself into the grimoire and
pouring my way through everything that I
could find and yeah that's where my
knowledge of everything really started
to develop you know like I'd taken a
look at things
prior in a very sort of non
non-committal way and from that moment
on I was committed and I just said you
know what we're gonna take a few days
and we're just gonna read through as
much of this as we can and by the end of
it I suddenly didn't have a complete
knowledge of everything you know like I
had a lot of misconceptions I probably
built in those first few days but I
certainly sat there with much more
knowledge than I had before and that was
the first building point to it and I
continued to build all that knowledge up
and then eventually in taking King I
took the first real plunge and then I
started making low content and it got a
little slightly more regular on the
channel and then by the time destiny too
came along I sort of said like okay time
to fully transition through all of this
you know cool and good cuz that's where
it really started like I refused I
refused to say that this game had no
story because when you I knew better you
know like any better than this idea of
like yeah Shore story versus Laura these
there is a distinction but everybody sat
there and said that the narrative team
didn't know what the hell they were
doing and maybe in terms of the main
campaign they didn't you know it was
three missions in dark below it wasn't
exactly riveting in destiny one but I
refused to say that they had built a
terrible world because I loved the world
and I had fallen in love with the idea
of a being a warlock and of you know
having these different orders and
tenants such as the praxic order or
thematter noughts or the jensen scribes
that you could always sort of like pull
back to you know like this world felt
like there was more and I wanted to know
more and I was engrossed and I didn't
want to let go of that and that's where
it all really started that's also just
what a follow up on that I love what you
said in reference to your desire your
fight of wanting more and knowing that
there has to be more here because we all
agree we all love this game we all feel
his death but I have to thank you
personally because when I fell in love
with destiny one I felt the same way and
with like you said earlier the the
running joke was story destiny you're a
sailor like there's no story I so on so
and in literally I would point people to
your video like you're the way you
described things even down to the
intricacies
of exotic weapons and reading lortabs
and stuff for that nature or just the
origins of something like the bad juju
or the last word and you know I'm saying
thorn and you know judging your and shin
malphur all these great story attributed
to these weapons and that's when I knew
I'm like dude it's the basic stories to
be told
and you were like in my opinion I don't
know you you're humble but you're the
Pioneer that for me but because at the
end of the day I would show people I
said you don't watch this video
you think that's thing doesn't have
story watch this video and you tell me
and people will go home okay there's
more here's just that they have budget
to do a better job of conveying it and
telling it obviously it's evolved since
so to look to you on that map because
you had definitely in the law could mean
it we have a lot of great guys and
you're definitely one of those that
definitely was in the forefront to help
pioneer and make it cool to say destiny
has a story mm-hmm like you know I want
to I want to go ahead and say that the
this is a little shout out I hope you
don't mind but the truth of all this the
og pioneer I think is unquestionably was
so Wallace it's always way back in the
day
oh my little I guess he I he is the
reason why I hesitated initially to jump
into law content because I was like I
don't want to crowd in on his stuff like
okay that's his that's his space and
then eventually as I've taught myself
down from such a silly notion as a
single like creator owning a space and
that's that's another thing that needs
to be highlighted is sleep you know I I
think I love the little community most
because of this notion that it doesn't
belong to any one person yeah you know
like there will occasionally be points
at which my followers will go ahead and
say no the law belongs to buy if and I
will literally go into this for it and I
will say stop it knowledge should be for
everyone
indeed and this is the thing right like
when you look at something as simple as
the very concept of truth truth is in
itself kind of blind like it doesn't it
doesn't care for one side of anything
truth in itself is a singular thing and
it doesn't belong to anybody it doesn't
necessarily favor anything intrinsically
it just is
right and it does any like we all have
different perspectives that give us a
lens on that truth and the only thing
that can possibly happen by another
person also jumping in in a law space is
that we get another one of those lenses
and if all those lenses add up we get a
more complete picture of everything
right now
so like ultimately that's how we have to
look at it like yes aiyah current I
think it's fair to say that I have the
biggest microphone when it comes to the
law community just based on sheer
numbers of Twitter followers a Youtube
subscriber is there any other silly
metric that you might use to measure it
but that does not mean that my voice is
more important
it certainly doesn't mean that my voice
needs to be the one that everyone
immediately refers to and it also
doesn't mean I'm the wisest and I feel
like to access the rest of it like it's
the most important thing we can do is
encourage more people to jump in so like
yeah I mean I think that's really the
number one thing I say that too like the
ideas of the law community generally as
a as a rule I think as well like there's
no such thing as like crowding someone
out of their space on content creation
it's just right people have their
preferences people watch what they want
to watch and at the end of the day the
idea that someplace is your space and
the crowd into it is childish nobody
owns this like it's not this one
person's sole property like everybody
can jump in to do this thing yeah
absolutely I mean literally if there
weren't people who believed that I
wouldn't be a thing we'd still have
woman doing his thing very very deep
like fairness to everybody who's jumped
in as well and like there are people who
don't like to watch mine instead will be
like okay I want to watch something like
say Milan or Milan for a podcast form
and I want to listen to a focus for chat
alternatively it's just hey I literally
only want to read the stuff myself and
then you had a Ishtar collective like
you know everybody has their own
different way of consuming this stuff
and being a part of it so that's how all
the different voices come together
awesome
like I said salute on their love the
humility as well really cool dude now
question I got from you in reference to
lore continuity and I think something
destiny
has been hit-or-miss something where you
know we've had these great characters or
great stories and then you know we have
a story campaign we have some cool
strikes that may tie in and then you
know it'll be give example one of the
one of the good examples I always point
through his stories like as far as the
um the taken king sock right and then
something like Forsaken where you have
that main campaign you have your
antagonist you have what's going on and
then the transition story wise right
into it and into the strikes and then me
which is very important the rate right
because I feel the ring is something
that destiny does so well it's such a
unique experience and like when you when
you beat the take and campaign and it's
like no it's not over
you know Eric's put sting down and now
we have to go confront orange right so
my question to you is what cuz one of
the point of contention we've had on
last word we said is that we'd have two
big expansive ravely only from the
standpoint because like you had
something like Hurstville cyrus and you
know you then you had what was it at
that time eater of worlds eater of world
and it just felt like such a disconnect
like why are we here
well what is the purpose use up saying
in comparison to the main story so like
what do you feel in reference the things
that maybe Bungie can improve story rise
as far as transitioning things or do you
think that you've seen tremendous
improvement now going up into the you
most recent continent
I think it really depends what you
highlight there back in cursive Osiris
and admittedly also in war mind is what
I think was a huge problem with the
structure of how they made stories and
expansions you know it was this idea
that the raid was completely separate
you know like we had Zola Norris Zavala
Rasputin and Anna Brae all stuffed into
war mind all stuffed into five story
missions two of which were strikes you
know like that in itself to me felt kind
of criminal in terms of the amount of
story opportunities that got squandered
you know like there's also literal worm
God and we killed him where the javel
like like that was for me
was one of the moments where seeing that
and then seeing that the raid layer was
another thing on the Leviathan was a bit
crushing because I sat there and I
thought isn't this the point at which we
can sit there and maybe seen like no
creases ascendant realm perhaps if you
maintain such a thing it's still kind of
that debates
seems out on that but I don't know like
yeah it would just felt like a
squandered opportunity right and you
know they admittedly did have good stuff
coming along later with whisper like
whisper was very much light on story
stuff but the implications just from
Zoll whispering and from the weapon that
you've got yeah fantastic and it was a
really good way of saying like hey we
haven't completely forgotten this
element of storytelling I'd say that it
got much better in Forsaken and I'd say
that from that point on they kind of
worked it through a lot of the stuff in
the expansions that followed and the
seasons that followed particularly
parades so the thing that was wonderful
about forsaken is that effectively it
all tied into this big story moment you
know like Ultron's death was effectively
the end of act 1 Riven's death was
effectively the end of act 2 and act 3
ended with dueling Caro at the end of
the shattered throne and the amazing
thing about all of that is it felt like
it had a coherent structure up until
like you know shatter throne came along
into chapter throne is an amazing piece
of content in terms of gameplay but
doesn't really have too much story
behind it in itself as the activity goes
like yes it's part of the Dreaming city
cycle and everything that comes with
that is phenomenal to speculate about
and truth to power is completely nuts
but the actual activity doesn't provide
you with many big story beats you know
it's it's a daughter of south foon and
you know that nothing narrative Lee
speaking goes on except for you kill her
for three weeks which sounds a little
odd to put it out there but yeah that's
that's where I think it fell apart
I'd say the Bungie has gotten better
weaving the raids into the story I say
they still need more work on it and I
think what's kind of demonstrated best
by Garden of salvation because you had
the end of the story right and you had
salvation and then it
a bit of a non-sequitur into the raid
right like Eris literally just starts it
and says they take us for fools and
slike the artifact just randomly started
emitting a signal
there's no cutscene to indicate that
Eris do you know like there's got to be
these conjoining moments you know these
joints to the different story arcs that
link it together and similarly with the
end of the raid you find one of the
statues similar to what you find in the
pyramid ship and that's right you know
the implications of that being in the
black garden in the first place at the
very top of the Mesa that everything
sort of centers around that has been
clearly cool you know part of the
darkness has reached to corrupt the
silver vessel from the very beginning
phenomenal story potential they don't
really do anything with it
if my feels about yeah you know
admittedly we admittedly we finished the
raid and then we get every weaker
communication from the darkness in the
unveiling book that's really awesome I
love that from the standpoint of the law
but you know the next story be we get
off to that is then Eris talking while
not talking but standing by and touching
the statue in the pyramid and like all
of these different moments in themselves
are good they're like they're like the
peaks of mountains you know or maybe
even just the bumps in you know the
hills between valleys they need bridges
connecting them otherwise they are
pointless they all agree fun little
fodder but they don't seem like part of
a connected story a whole bunch of loose
threads that need to yeah they have some
energy I agree and it can also sort of
bleeds into the continuity of the
seasons and how they're working out too
because take a look at like what seems
to be the overarching theme of this
entire year which is the arrival of the
darkness you know you have shadow keep
and the undying mind and how will that
plays out and that's pretty cool but
then immediately the season after that
is saint-14
yeah it's just this three months the
saint-14 stuff which is great like I
loved it it was really good but had no
it had next to no bearing except for
maybe one law entry on bungie.net and a
few hints and pieces there with the
Empyrean foundation it didn't relate to
shadow keep at all even like you know
it's great to bring back same I'm so
glad
and but there was no continuity you know
like it feels like we've just again just
now starting to really strongly pickup
that storyline of the darkness
researching with the warming bunker and
the approaching dots every week right
you know like that's really awesome
seeing like a physical reminder of these
guys are getting closer every single day
being dual we literally have a Doomsday
Clock just think about that we have an
actual Doomsday Clock coming up at the
end of the season it's gonna be on top
of us basically and yet when we sit here
and look at that it bears no relation to
the season prior the almighty stuff
which is posted as you know that along
the rasputin is the main kind of draw of
this season also is not really truly
related to the darkness stuff like yes
they're responsible then immediately
fall into how rasputin's to fight the
darkness but it didn't start that way
and then he ran all of that's done that
bear that will no relation to say 14
either like you know but at the very
beginning of this season I was convinced
that we were gonna have like a cabal
themed ending to the season that we'd be
like tying off the keidel story with all
of that you know yeah and I don't know
like it's just it's really perplexing to
see three months of nothing on the
darkness and then suddenly there front
and center again so that's the thing
that I really want Bungie to focus on I
want them to take a single enemy or a
single storyline or a single you know
idea even and just run with it and use
that for an entire year's worth of
content you don't need to be facing the
same enemy every time you don't like to
always have the same characters in that
story be you can go around to other
characters and talk about different
things but you've got to be able to like
have a narrative the points people going
because otherwise it feels like you're
picking up these narrative threads and
then just dropping them and that's so
irritating to viewers and to people who
are following the story because at the
end of the day you know what that
creates it creates these moments like
with Aldrin solve when he gets
resurrected a year right boy you know
angry yeah you hear one lortab
after that a year later and now nada no
not Faizal not a single word on aldrin
ah like they have great writers they
have the ability to make these good
story beats they just need the
connective tissue I can come they little
you don't forget about where this stuff
is going you know like in matron before
I passed it fantastic what is that the
thing that also bothers me is sometimes
I consider it um character or NPC
interaction after major events and I
feel like sometimes like taking point
like we took yeah right right
no none bigger like it did this time all
right
we just saved saint-14 we you know we go
to the infinite forest we do this
amazing thing you know you know you hear
the reference that or Cyrus has force a
party there's no cut seed with them two
together talking there's no interaction
and then okay now trials is built we did
the you know the foundation that's great
you know
Osiris when you stay I mean say 14 when
you stand next to him he will say cool
things about Osiris and so on and so
forth what he's doing but it would be so
cool just push out the WD press gotta
change yeah no bro hug where is the like
three pat slap on the back of guys like
dude it's been too long like it's
wearing like that this man literally
said is one of my biggest regrets in the
whole creation of the sundial was for
this purpose and right yeah there is not
one cinema no interaction even same
thing similar things with um Anna and in
salalah it's just like you know we just
need that NPC connective thread on a
communication about big events that just
happen that have affected this world and
no one's talking about it it's like uh
on to the next like you know it's great
to have some moments like this mentioned
in law tops right like I think there's a
ship this season which talks about how
as a baller at the end of one of his
days goes to meet Amanda and then
they're just having a little bit of
quiet conversation it's clear that
zeevala is tired and then he says hey
take a break let's go get some food and
then immediately she says let's go for
ramen like that's
that's such a great little moment to
having a law to have but there's got to
be more moments like that whenever big
on screen main characters are coming
forward and having these bits like but
you know the one time when that does
actually happen the connection between
saint and Osiris isn't truly that in a
certain sense because it's one of his
reflections you guys ever been to the
lighthouse as in flawless I have not yet
so you need to educate us when you go
flawless when you actually reach the
lighthouse pull out a sniper rifle okay
turn subtitles on and scope out the
actual box where saint-14 is standing
you will see Osiris there except it's
one of his reflections and then it will
bug out they'll have a short
conversation before you get there nice
right and it's not in here's the thing
you need subtitles on because you're not
close enough to hear it
achoo right you need to have them on so
you can actually make it out in the
first place you can only just see them
making the exchange and it's a little
tiny easter egg that bungees left in
there it's all that's gone it's all hint
but there should be more than that and
it was so important it's so important
because of like oh god I almost don't
want to talk about it because there's
law behind the lighthouse and I mean
look at things like the Saints vocation
ship and a whole bunch of the others
that have come alongside this new season
there is more to the lighthouse than
just getting through trials loot and
being flawless like yeah long story
short the original destiny one
lighthouse emitted basically a musical
tone of two notes one of which which was
quote warm and smooth and the other of
which which was called cold and sharp
right like doesn't that remind you of a
duality that we currently have in
distance right now yeah it's it's light
and darkness right like simple as that
so when it comes down to it that's
really huge and it seems as though that
was planted there originally on Mercury
by the darkness so that's terrifying
saint-14 and Osiris have some time where
they are basically investigating this to
a certain extent and they're
investigating it partly because of [ __ ]
brother Vance has been doing but way
back in the original destiny one trials
part of the reason why he was getting us
to do trials of Osiris was because he
was effectively taking that feed and
allowing himself to listen to the
lighthouse because he was one of the
only ones who could actually hear that
tone and every time a Guardian died it
would make a note and so he was studying
the music of the lighthouse and he even
got you know there's points at which I
believe the current one that's out is
actually a point which he goes before
Morris selves and he talks about this
and she says do not pursue it she
deliberately says don't go after it
you'll understand why in time but don't
go after it
do not miss you this spoiler alert I
think it's pretty clear that he's gonna
ignore her you know like it's a Friday
we'll get the new cards to out publicly
to everybody know it's already available
an Ishtar collective but yeah like get
it yeah point being um the White House
is up to no good
the lighthouse is not a man-made
structure it is very much something
that's been left behind by another force
and yes what it's used for is not
necessarily known but the implications
of what ends up happening are huge and
terrifying and ya know there's a real
story there but like it's got to be
expanded on you know you got to be yeah
I got boy I know no no like we'll just
cook okay okay now conversely now no we
we kind of attacked them a little bit as
far as you know things that they need to
improve on
now one thing there's a little bit of
controversy I got a shot to my boy law
reports all Tassie we've had on the last
word for amazing writer football and I
remember one point of contention
initially that we had was the devil's
ruin exotic quest and a lot of people in
the community were very upset but they
were like you know it gave the gun away
it was too short a quest and yada yada
now I was actually on the other side of
it and the reason why I was was because
I felt that yes the quest was short it
was very easy to obtain but one of the
gems that I've always wanted was the law
and the
the voice acting between saint-14
and chefs oh that dude I was so
emotional just here I'm like this is the
type of stuff I've always worn it from
destiny and they just stay at Twilight
gap they're talking about the story safe
14 is reintroduced to shacks again they
talk about the state of the crucible the
jokes are inbound we got Shaq singing is
such a gem in my opinion I'm biased cuz
I do I'm a warlike being but I know some
of my favorite tight shacks is
definitely one of my favorites it's just
to see that interaction even though
stars like okay Guardian these two will
go at it all day
they'll be honest for one I'll leave you
to wonder about the world I think it's a
girl right yes so how did you feel about
that just your overall thoughts about
that question how may be the law was
here I think it highlights one really
important thing which is somehow whether
it's through adventures or whether you
can do it via another throwing dialogue
into lost sectors or whether it's just
by having banter over the comms at
various controlled inter phases and its
various points destiny needs to have a
way of allowing more of that dialogue to
exist in a structured manner because
here's the thing that quest is so great
to us as destiny players because we're
starved of it but in most other mmo's in
most other online games where characters
like that talking on the regular it
would be not exactly 100% commonplace
but it would be much more expected brand
we are starved for that in destiny and
I'll admit it's a different format than
all of that but there needs to be a
different way in which Bungie can insert
more of the stuff like this insert these
great into character moments because
yeah like The Devil's ruin question
itself gameplay wise was yeah it's a Sun
Dial run and then running around
Twilight gap by the way somehow someone
thinks that's worth two hundred and
fifty dollars on a carry site by the
waves oh my god yeah yeah it's
discounted today it's 225 making me deal
oh damn
my spice Nook anyway point that's
totally aside for him a point being like
yeah the gameplay wasn't much but it
shows how valuable those story moments
and those stories really are so at the
end of the day I think the most
important thing for bungie to take away
from that is simply bring more of those
moments to the fore make sure that
you're making use of them and always
always always remember that if you're
going to have more of this dialogue it's
always gonna be better like even if
there's little moments which you don't
really think you can fit in you could
have them a spare like broken up bits of
conversation that you find somewhere in
the game you know almost love what I
would almost love is if we could have a
thing which was just quote intercepted
transmissions right so you could
literally have intercepted conversations
of people who are standing by on a radio
or who are talking to each other over a
radio you know like if you're standing
in the a DZ and a few other locations
actually you can actually find a radio
that spits out live transmissions and
stuff you know you'll have say Hawthorne
and a fender not Fenchurch Who am I
thinking of his husband is Mark he's up
in the tower
devvra yeah so you'll have you'll have
Hawthorne and dev room and Amanda
coordinating evacuations in the EDC for
Refugees that need to be taken to the
farm right like you'll just see that
stuff spitting out of the radio I want
an option to be able to play that stuff
yeah it's like random intercepted
transmissions that you can pick up
throughout the game which add a little
intrigue you know like it doesn't even
need to be something that is guaranteed
to give you anything it just adds flavor
to the world that's really important for
the sake of context you know I really
wish there was something along those
lines and you know maybe the structure
that I have in place right now is fine
but if it is fine it's only fine if
there's more stuff like it I agree you
know like there should be more that's
Paul the reason why Devils ruin for any
of us was really sort of salvageable as
an exotic quest was because it had an
unusually large amount of dialogue which
I think
is what all of them should be like yep
yeah it was it was the perfect like I
said interaction between the characters
as well yeah I loved it
yeah oh no you got one no first no like
that was I've never waited for a timer
to go down to zero is gonna happen other
than it resets is there more and I just
said I was like I had my recording going
the whole time I'm like something else
you know what's funny I had the exact
same experience also champion of Cohen
who's over in the twitch stream for this
right now says something very good which
is like the most toenails yeah something
like that except more accessible you
know the most common oils are discovered
and they're fantastic in that sense
because contextually in terms of where
they are they make a ton of sense it's
fantastic
for the sake of telling the story of
Clovis Bray and the cradle of invention
where you find yourself on Mars but
outside of the future escape I'd love to
be able to just place something from my
ship you know intercept transmissions
like absolutely yeah I was just gonna
say like because I was talking about
brother about it too by the way my
brother's nephews your for our history
of destiny they mean they're like 10 13
I always don't quite know their ages
they watched it twice Wow what like they
have watched that thing twice and he's
like you know they're kids they want to
run around they were mesmerised so I
just wanted to give you that night out
from thank you but no I was like I was
talking to my brother and he was saying
the way you've done many of yours
between like Marcus's art and stuff like
that Bungie has some great artists and
even if as you were saying like hey at
the end of st. fourteens season with
Howe Cyrus if there was like like an
animated storyboard maybe it's not a
full cinematic but if they you could
have something like those animated
storyboards stuck in or ways to like a
way to kind of kick off the raid and
things that you guys were mentioning
those little pieces and places that
don't cost quite as much development
resources but then actually put the
story front and center for the people
who are like hey what's the raid and
there's a couple you know animated
storyboards that go through does it take
quite the production cost but I was
wondering lots of trying to bring
something like that into it
I think anything where they can help
portray more of the story is going to be
good but I think has per usual the
discussion for them is going to be in
terms of cost and when I say cost I mean
cost in terms of the development sense
not in terms of money you know when it
comes to development cost is often a
case of like your capacity to actually
create something you know it's it's a
huge task to be able to create say the
cutscenes from taking King you know
especially considering nowadays the
expectation of higher fidelity and the
requirement of many you know studios to
be able to keep up with what is expected
story wise and I'm glad now that they're
doing more in engine moments because I
have a feeling yes that's probably
simpler for them to do and then they
could probably do that amongst
themselves and it doesn't need to be
something that they expedite to some
other place Orion will not expedite
expedite is the wrong word I think
outsource yes there we go yeah yeah
completely correct but ya know when it
comes to that stuff any moment where we
can get some kind of interaction prior
to an activity is important and getting
more of that stuff in the game would
absolutely help
it's why I'm much more happy about
things such as say you know the
conversations between Anna and Zavala in
the ass focus you know it seems it seems
like really small things but if you
chart that alongside all the other
changes they've been doing they've
slowly been working towards making a
more nimble sort of case for telling the
story in the game so you know even take
a look at a year ago black armory was
coming out that was the first time where
they did a thing where your camera
panned to the center of the screen as
they as someone was delivering dialogue
to you yes otherwise be a vendor scene
and it seems like a really small thing
but that's so important because it takes
you out of that sort of mentality of
this is a vendor screen you know
normally you'll have
all the quests sitting alongside as
they're delivering dialogue you'll be
grabbing all of those and you'll be
chatting to a buddy if you reduce that
uim and center the camera on them and
just have to subtitle text all of a
sudden it's a very different story it's
a case of Oh uh-oh something's happening
oh I should listen to this you know it's
so it's subtle little changes and
adaptations to the engine like that that
really make this you know a change worth
jumping into and absolutely
like there's small things that you
absolutely need to bring on and then
there's the bigger things like dialogue
you know like I I really just hope that
they expand on that no matter what
happens yeah I really do I really think
it's something that again especially the
law community we really appreciate all
those little nuances when they do it
because there's so much to be told so I
love that kind of what I wanted to ask
you to us I'm just like a sillies
perspective was like MPC right and I
don't mean II we've done this before
we've kind of like ranked our like top
three or like favorite MPC just ready to
go pass in the game world and you just
love their dialog or just really
resonate with the character so I know we
did the warlock thing which if they walk
is but from an NPC standpoint get me
like the bike top you know stay top five
NPCs running around the game world that
our favorites were you know God two of
them easily sure og and Toland just for
their implementations patrols like the
fact that they are there to provide you
more context on the world is fantastic
but I also think I love tollens just
because you know like occasionally
you'll pass by him on a sparrow and then
he'll be like come shop oh yes you know
an occasional it'll be a little bit more
like it'll be a little bit more BM you
know it'll be like calm squanderer and
it's like well okay yeah I like it
perfectly fits into his character and
everything so unquestionably though I
think Toland clearly tops that even
though we got tolling we got sure
roachie we're gonna need some more now
one more or not just or just
just as many many let's go he's like all
of them
okay maybe some standouts mmm oh man
that's really tough I think saint-14 in
the tower is fantastic just began sighs
or actions during the world you know
have you seen the have you see I don't
know if you've seen this one contest but
as a Titan have you walked up to with
the helm of saint-14 if you're so if you
walk up to him and you're also wearing
the helm of saint-14 he'll turn around
and look at you and be like ah just like
me confuse them all with this he's such
a wholesome character but like the
comedy gold that he's occasionally yes
he's like I beat you the children one
point that you would laugh and you are
the ones who will make them cry yes like
hilarious but he was announced to be the
the trials announcer of like I can't
that it cannot get any better and I love
Shaq's no get me wrong
Shaq's is like gold but definitely I
gotta stay safe with he kills the
announcing bit so that's a good choice
though one of the best majors I'd say
spiders Idol dialogue and even the stuff
that you get even if you're just getting
patrols from him it's really fascinating
too because he's the only real like he's
a crime lord but like let's not mince
words at all he's not some upstanding
fall and gentlemen of the shore he is a
crime he's very you know he is yeah he's
the following Yakuza boss and the really
fascinating thing about that is not just
the fact that he says all the things
you'd expect him to say like a new
monarchy shipment wound up on my shore
we can get it back to them for a price
you know it's the fact that all of this
culture isn't actually his right leg
fallen who've adopted that culture
we're very much adopting it from Old
Earth traditions and that's what's
really fascinating it's something that
you can see with gangs like the Kell
scourge there's actually um this time
last year there's a law book that came
out called them stolen intelligence and
it was basically a bundle of stolen
Vanguard reports from the hidden and one
of them was on the state of the Fallen
at current and he talks about say just
the state of how they are as a society
now the really interesting thing about
that is that they've lost a whole bunch
of their cultural touchstones whether
that's you know their actual home planet
because of course that was lost in their
version of the collapse called the
whirlwind or whether it's their old
traditions such as the ways of old that
verax talks about or whether it's even
the old house structure because nowadays
the only house that's really still
around and making a resurgence is the
House of Devil's under aramis and you
know the house of dusk is basically just
a big conglomeration of fallen they
don't really have much in common other
than their will to survive and out of
that a whole bunch of scavenging gangs
have looked at Earth's culture and it's
become their own because they didn't
know their own they haven't known their
own world and so they are the first of a
new generation of fallen who don't have
any kind of you know cultural heritage
to cling on to and the spider as a
result becomes this really fascinating
NPC because of that kind of mix of Earth
culture and Alixe me you know he is he
is such a wonderful picture of
adaptability because he's taken what
works for him in that moment out of a
blend of both his own characteristics
the adaptations that need to be made his
environment both because of
physiological requirements and because
of the society that he finds himself in
and also he's just good luck with it
while he's doing it all he's out a good
old tab rolling in I called me ultimate
hustler magazine from you got to see
what the price of certain materials are
this week this day as inflation rate is
like outs
yeah what do you want enhancement cause
well we can arrange that I'm sure how
much how many years are you lucky to be
indebted to me 100 percent per purchase
go see those like when it comes to NPCs
the one that actually it was just kind
of like tickles me when I don't expect
it is failsafe
oh she's amazed you'll be going through
and then it's like oh that's like and
I'm said just the bipolar nature of
failsafe yes one of those completely
unexpected things feel like walking
around neces is a completely beautiful
planet and then you have the most
sarcastic AI robot in your ear that is
bipolar on top of it and I'm just
sitting over here I was like this is
amazing this is like this is how you buy
a pass like just like making me actually
pay attention to the dialogue it's not
like you know the smooth tones of devran
K or bife de pending on who's voicing
that one for the time being but but no
fail-safe just she cracks me up and then
of course Asher is pissed off all the
time but oh action mirror is as a place
in my heart yes I will ask him what the
destructive capacity of the old mighty
is in joules you will say I know I do
not know for I am the reckless fool
there's so many fantastic lines there
and also can I just say I may be the
only person who does this but I get half
of the stuff that he's talking about in
the German strike and I'm like continue
continue listen to something like in the
central and the wait and simpler numeral
criticality or something and you'll sit
there and be like okay in terms of what
a vex is I think I kind of get what
you're talking about and then it'll be
like oh why do I bother explaining it to
you and I'm like you could have just
kept going going no one else would have
cared but I would have make it so much
fun for like blue people my interactions
between him and I Cora it is just I
would I do that per medium and I'm just
like bear he is going off and did she
get sassy would have like didn't see
this to my face
which is it's such a great point too
because I Corps is one of the only
people who's beaten shacks in the
crucible yeah yeah like I chorus like
low-key still I've come around since d2
I've come around and I'm like in the
last thing they're not to interrupt you
with Cades death mmm
I really really resident yes cuz she's
like what she calls the vollis a deep
with that what I was like made out that
was some good stuff right there but yeah
you are absolutely right by I think I
have such more of an appreciation for
her and obviously her story how strong
she is you know obviously as a warlock
and stuff which actually leads me in my
special which is in reference to hunter
Bhangarh hmm we know r.i.p the legend a
myth but we have a situation right and
we have you know a man who's been
resurrected he doesn't know his past
actions and you know the hunter dare and
then the other thing I want to in
reference to obviously we know he's
candidate you know for that but the
other question is obviously Anna Bradley
bungee recently you I didn't they change
the actress yeah they changed the voice
that breast for Anna so again I could be
looking more into it than it needs to be
but you know when I ceased that from
Bungie I assume that they're going to be
utilizing this character more right so
my question is by for you as reference
to the aldryn situation how they need to
handle it that they the hunters don't
have a vanguard it's been a while right
you've got pyramid ships coming all this
stuff with the hunters need a fair guard
and then could Anna brain even be a
candidate in the mix as well it's just
all drinks job all the way where do you
stand on the state of the hunters so the
way that I look at it is this every
hunter is a candidate right this is
something that the tower is very clear
on right they
basically let the hunters decide for
themselves but have you read Tommy's
matchbook I have no water
okay so Tommy's matchbook expands on
this point this is a point of which on
or another wonderful praxic warlock yeah
she goes into a hunter's den and it's
completely deserted and it leads into a
story where she talks with the one
hunter in his ghost that they can find
and it talks about how the hunters are
abandoning the city and going on their
own quests or taking long assignments
away from any vanguard duties because
they don't want to be scouted for the
vanguard mentor position one hate the
vanguard mental position because he ties
them down and it screws with their
ability because of innate system yeah
yeah exactly like hunters bide every
nature or Scouts you know they all
suppose to roam free in the wild and
being stuck behind the walls of the city
forever in meetings and different
moments of administration he's not the
hunt his way right like there's just the
nature of it acts so when you sit there
and you have any hunter potentially
being a candidate what are they gonna do
they're all gonna scatter right having
said all of that even though every
hunter is a candidate I would be
astounded I truly would be stunned if
they'd said to hey let's make Anna the
hunter thank God because yes you could
confound expectations by doing that but
I don't know if there's a point to it
and beyond all of that it would not fit
her character right in the sense of her
free roaming nature she is very much
somebody who will just go ahead and find
herself out in the wild you know she is
the kind of person who wants to be
roaming free and her motor sovereign
died for doing that
yeah her motive for all that is
basically all around Rasputin Rasputin
yeah you know it's like she is tied to
him in that sense partly because of her
family legacy and partly because of her
belief that his power is really
important to the system survival so for
her it would never be something that she
would willingly take up and she would
just continue to flee that Duty simply
because of the fact
she has this connection to the war mind
you know and this is the thing that idea
of having something more important than
vain God duties whilst also being a
vanguard has happened before or Cyrus
Cyrus literally sat there and said hey
if we're gonna go ahead and protect
things we can't just look to the
immediate present threats which would
probably be like the Fallen and
defending the walls and reclaiming
various bits of local territory at a
time being no you had to look to the
future you had to look to the things
that could potentially destroy us would
be some Oh Cyrus that's right yeah I
mean you go through all that same
thinking and that same process and the
more that you think about it Aldrin is
the only candidate for hunting
absolutely do this because he not only
has fulfilled the vanguard dare but also
he is a blank slate of a character now
that he's lost his memory he has no
potential affiliation to any other group
because no one has shown him any love he
has this moment where he may realize
what he's done and he may try to atone
for it and prove it ultimate and beyond
yeah and beyond all of that assuming
that you know all of the stars do a line
and everybody actually has a moment
where they're compelled to forgive him
for what he did he's he's one of these
people who does not necessarily have any
kind of prior obligations right like
let's take a famous hunter at any period
in history I don't know if they're still
alive at this moment in time but Shinobu
and the six coyotes Shinobu already has
a hunter posse right she's already got
the group of people that she'll be
roaming around with she's got people
that she's missing you know when you
take a look at previous Vanguard's like
handle brass you know part of the reason
why their group then falls apart is
because they're missing one of their
hunters you know him Shiro and Kade used
to run operations over time you know and
now they don't you know partly because
handles dead and partly because Kate's
dead and yeah
[Music]
as Edna mode would say no capes yeah you
know he has no one in the world and he's
not tied to any particular organization
he is for the most part can we forgive
him right like like like I've made peace
with the fact that he's a different
person but not everyone in the community
has you know like this is the thing it's
it's very much one of those well written
kind of paths of a character I think
because it is a real question that
Guardians grapple with is I understand
that this person is the same person in
terms of his body but a different person
in terms of his mind and personality and
maybe even choices but it really does
make us sit there and ask some important
questions as a result you know can you
forgive someone for you know actions
that they had no control over in what is
effectively a past life as a different
person yeah he is a guardian similar to
their past life in any way shape or form
you know that's something else that with
Aldrin we probably have a good case
study for does someone truly deserve
forgiveness in circumstances like these
you know all these important questions
Bungie has basically thrust upon us and
said you will have to internalize this
and think about it and deal with it in
time figure out how you feel and then
we'll go ahead and we'll keep telling
the story astiz and whilst they've not
picked up the alterans stuff in ages and
while they've teased us with moments
here or there I do wish that they've
given us more little inciting a story
because you know who Aldrin is right now
you know who he is it's a game of
Thrones reference so if you guys haven't
yeah right now as his resurrected form
he's basically reek right he's right
good yeah is the reek to the previous
film yes yes and he doesn't remember his
old life so to speak in the similar way
that
rique does not acknowledge that theon
exists anymore for the sake of his own
safety you know like it is very much a
case of he needs to be able to
understand what happened and what care
for he's a different person in that
certain sense like he's been robbed of
his humanity yeah like that there is a
there is a real parallel that because
it's gonna have to be a case if you've
got a you know reconcile those two
identities and the present in the past
and you've got to say like okay do I
have any responsibility for what
happened back then can i really be held
accountable for all this what's going on
like where do i chart my path from now
on you know like when it comes to the
vanguard I mean Zavala and everything
that's been done through I Corps
training under Osiris when it comes to
the van card and the Vanguard and then
being you know in the place that they
are somebody who I mean so the knowledge
of like how much memory is wiped and
stuff like that it's like to have such a
clean slate of almost no experience I
kind of want to ask you like is there
any idea of what is retained for
somebody to be late not to say like hey
he's a baby going in where it completely
knows nothing but to say somebody as a
fresh vanguard to be our fresh Guardian
to be a vanguard is there anything that
makes that like a weird step it means
like story wise and everything we're
saying totally makes sense but it's like
fresh Guardian you be the vanguard that
seems like a very quickly to get into
that position velocity I just kind of
wondered what your thought on that would
be for it to be like your new Guardian
BAM you run this place like really earn
the position well yeah just kind of just
like I mean just as what just this time
to be you know a guardian and you know
feel I feel like Zavala I Cora previous
you know vanguards and stuff have been
around for longer at least through the
story as opposed to he's been a van he's
been a guardian for in in the sake of
things like five minutes and then he's
gonna run one of these things so I just
kind of gear thoughts of like him being
so fresh if that has any weight or if
the hunters deer dare kind of outweighs
like his freshness to this role so I
think there's two things to really
consider here one is the three things
one is that there have been past
examples namely us in
story what fresh Chaldeans have still
accomplished amazing things so you know
being fresh it's not necessarily the
immediate measure of one's success like
yeah sure you're less likely to
understand it and even we had to learn
how to wield the golden gun if we were a
hunter or how to throw an arc bolt
grenade if we were a warlock but you
know like all of these different moments
do not necessarily allow some kind of
immediate judgment of someone's capacity
at the end of things right that's the
first important thing to really note on
it
the other thing I would say on top of
all of this is I think this is going to
be a point where we'll see all trans
character develop in a big mainstay
expansion and then lists like the
capping of all of that expansion will
effectively be Aldrin learns his place
becomes a vanguard and is able to take
up that mantle you know it's gonna be
one of these things of the campaign so
to speak will be his proving ground the
only thing I'd say is that at this point
as a guardian alterans about a year and
a half old
you know like in in our terms by this
point you know Aldrin has definitely not
accomplished the same things as we have
by this point we were killing the taken
king right yeah like you know we we a
beautifully set a very high bar we you
know we killed we killed a God three
months into our life that's pretty small
we then killed his dad nine months after
that you know there's no perfect parity
on but there is definitely room for a
guardian to grow in that amount of time
it's not unprecedented you know even
when it comes to someone like say Zavala
you see in his origin story how he
learned in the wild on his own yeah to
basically fight and mammalian waste and
I am so out of the city like dog Ian's
can do crazy things even if there are
only a few days old you know like that
mm-hmm
ya know I think they're all about yeah
there are things worth looking into for
that and it's worth remembering but even
a young Guardian can do incredible
things as location for me um the space
to the impending
oh look you know this has been a theme
you know me have talked about this a lot
and as far as when they gonna do it you
know obviously shadow keep drops with
like Bowl they're doing it you know we
maybe they've been they've been doing it
we just didn't know yeah we just didn't
know it but the moon possessed so yeah
we had that before the question can i oh
yes because cuz I cuz I can see the look
on your faces you're talking about oh
it's happening and I remember the exact
moment when I realized that because I
was at Bungie playing it for the first
time you played the first mission and
they told us okay you're allowed to
record up to this point you can't record
beyond that and there was like a group
of three or four people through a bunch
employees behind my monitor as I turned
the corner to see the ship for the first
time they were just and I think I drop I
like dropped my controller and just hold
my my face in my hands and I was like oh
my god oh oh you did it oh you did it
oh they bow you oh this is happening
this is real okay yes of your reaction
that inspires the writers to continue to
wow us because of your dropping the
controller quote drop the mic like
you're a moment yeah I was like that's
awesome
I can't imagine what that feeling
honestly I feel like there was an
expletive or two there was yeah we all
were in amazement we're just like wow
they're doing it we're talking about it
you know and we're gonna deal with
something so we had that you know
transition guard and salvation even a
little bit more context at the end of
the Ray when you beat the Ray you know
saying and it's like now Rasputin we go
to rest moon every week they've got that
do them stakeout we seed it there in the
sources so my question is in reference
it and again me is talked about this a
lot you know how they handler because
initially we the rumors are with what we
thought well maybe this would be a d3
thing
they would kind of extend this out and
we wouldn't get this but according to
this you know they're in the system but
they are approaching and me had this
conversation you know in reference to
the storyline and real-time Bungie you
know shout to Luke Smith and these guys
say hey the games getting too big you
know um you know things can exist the
way they are certain things are going to
have to go so what do you say to a
theory that we've been in bouncers have
talked about in reference that something
may have to go like you know like it
like a Titan or something any small moon
by the way not the class guys just so
you know the Titan has to Clara Guardian
games so the thing is like I always felt
like something cataclysmic needs to have
we need to feel a sense of like that
they're coming right what do you feel
how how does that need to be heads or
something cataclysmic it blown up like
it's common so how do you how do you
think they should handle it I think the
likely case is that they're gonna
destroy a planet or a moon I like one of
the d1 base destinations so you're
looking at I don't think they destroy
the e DZ because that's - but hey that's
too close
that's too far on the system and be you
know like hi you destroyed earth what
what now no but no I feel like if
they're gonna do something I'd look
Nessus Titan and IO I would sit there
and say they are very likely candidates
for the ax notice look they know
absolutely cuz you know at the end of
the day this is content that not
everybody plays not everybody uses Titan
in particular is just I mean many of you
guys gone to Titan aside from what
randomly dropped you there in a sarong I
literally said I was like
there but no I'm just kidding but I was
like rest in peace loan if we do this
like if we do this what do we
realistically lose okay we lose Greg the
fabled ogre and there's the least amount
of strikes - per planet because it just
has Sabbath in some it just has
everything so yeah so in total I feel
like if that's taking up a lot of room
that's a candidate for the block but by
that same token I don't know how you
reconcile that with also having to keep
it in the game the story missions but
maybe yes maybe the patrol zone is
different from Titan itself actually in
a story mission I don't know it's a it's
a question that I'm not 100% sure of by
the way yeah like I think it's very
likely that you will see one of those
destinations axed entirely and I feel
like not only is that something that
makes sense in terms of content but also
some of those locations can make room
for other stuff that can be added which
will get played more because here's the
thing like forges might not be played
too much gambit pro man reckoning might
not be played too much but if they can
create something on a scale of
replayability - Menagerie it will be
worth the space and I think that
everybody will be very happy about that
and also going back to the original
point of like the pressing threat of
things yes
the darkness is very much capable of
destroying a moon you know they've
decimated Titan before you want to know
the reason why all the arcologies are
all kind of bummed up and broken and
full educator there is a law book that
we got back in shadow keep look tipped
actually from the season of the undying
because you acquired it through vex
offensive but it was called the last
days on crack and Mari and it talks
about how the darkness basically
destroyed the arcologies on Titan during
the collapse and the events that led up
to that on the human scale and to give
you a vague idea of it I want you to
imagine this everybody get your physics
brains together and
understand things okay so let's give the
example of earth right you have earth
and then you have our moon our moon
creates a gravitational pull just in the
same way that our earth Korea's
gravitational pull on it but for the
moon that creates the tides and it's
constantly rotating around us in orbit
because I listened to something recently
with yeah basically that's the vague
idea you know like the moon will be able
to pull on water and that's how tides
are created it's literally gravitational
forces like you know when you have the
equinox you've got the Sun and the moon
pulling in unison which is why you get
the strongest tides then here's the
thing the moon in the Sun will pull
constantly at the tides but we're
rotating on our axis as a planet and you
know the moon is orbiting us and so
these these forces are always in motion
but imagine if you had all of that
gravitational energy to a point right
and effectively what you'd get is you
get more gravity on one side of the moon
than the other and then all of a sudden
that pulls water and whatever else is
pulled up by gravity towards that point
that singular point on the world right
so imagine this is in geosynchronous
orbit the way that the darkness has
previously decimated Titan is by
basically causing that big
geosynchronous orbit point of gravity
and it pulled a whole massive load of
water to that point it created a bulge
of something like I think it's 60 meters
they talked about in the law book but
imagine that 60 meters there's meters
not feet all right so that's 200 feet
roughly right you know that's it that's
a tidal wave of the day aftertomorrow
kind of proportions and all of a sudden
when the gravitational force stops and
when the planet is no longer being
pulled that wave is then released and it
creates what is known as you know this
massive tidal wave which in the book saw
or something similar kind of happens
which is called the CCG which supposedly
was caused by the alignment of 52 moons
or something you know all of them
pulling at unison at one
singular point because they were all
aligned and they were all pulling at the
same direction the darkness is capable
of a similar power and the amazing thing
of all of that comes together to simply
put is one thing it's a way of
destroying a world because not only you
pulling on the water you're also pulling
on the planets superstructure right so
crack and moire which is the ocean
beneath Titans methane oceans has a
crust of ice and when the gravitational
forces and their shockwave compounds
back it shatters like it just completely
and utterly crumbles in on itself and
there's this massive tidal wave of force
that isn't just the force of the water
moving it's also the force of the energy
that's been expelled by it you know look
this is a huge amount of energy coming
yes and from what we can tell this was
really only the first attack of the
darkness if we're gonna look what an
entire fleet of darkness ships could do
if they can pound on a single world I
mean you only need to look at what was
happening to the planet they talk about
how instead of being spherical sorry not
planet the moon instead of being
spherical Titan wasn't was oblong you
know it was like an egg that's how much
is being pulled
he said you're much more interesting
than science plants continue but yeah if
you take that massive like idea of a
planet being pulled so much that it
basically becomes egg-shaped and you
keep pulling you come to the natural
conclusion that you could rip a planet
literally apart can you imagine the
gravitational force that requires can
you even conceive of it because it
happens to I on a semi-regular basis you
want to know why io in the real world is
so volcanic it's because it's got
Ganymede to the biggest moon of Jupiter
and Jupiter the biggest planet in the
solar system pulling on it often in
opposite direction so it's consistently
being pulled apart and the activity that
happens as a result is fall
Kanak explosive and very volatile you
always have changed on iOS surface
because it's never able to sit still
long enough to create solid landmarks
and everything like you have volcanoes
that will pop up all the time because
it's unstable as all hell that is you
know not exactly going to be the same as
what happens to Titan because it's all
an ocean but if you want to conceive of
how to destroy a planet the own
gravitational force to a single point is
definitely one of the ways you could
potentially do it and it sounds crazy
and the amount of force that you'd need
to do that is huge but if there is a
power causal entity in the universe that
has the weapons to do so isn't
definitely the darkness it's definitely
definitely the darkness and they've used
these gravity weapons before or yeah
they used it on Yang Liwei with like
ship that basically birth to the awoken
there's a whole bunch of stuff that
indicates that they may have this theory
at least that indicates they may have
done that way back when with the hive
like they may originally have caused the
CCG which is the theory but that's again
very much speculative theory so don't
grab it as though it's definite yeah
like there is something that is totally
destructive to a world that they could
do and I do not doubt that if Bungie
wanted to destroy a world that they've
been dropping these lore bits throughout
the years to hint at that possibility
like this is one of those super weapons
this is what they can do it seems like
the obvious choice I mean at least in
when you say it that way and it's like
the the moon and everything there and
it's also sitting next to now okay this
is where a bad soil spin foil hat wants
to kind of check a questionable thought
with these boys so my brother and I were
talking about the potential of the
pyramid ships and I did my random
speculation video after talking to him
for a little bit and honestly this is
just what I wanted to run by and again
the big thing about Sabitha and being
always the trickster and even I've
listened to you say it as well it's like
you could take a whole lot of what she
says with a grain of salt so
everything always seems to be pretty
questionable but I was honestly
wondering if potentially like the
pyramid ships are coming if there was
any way and again it's always the
question of like is the darkness
actually an entity and then that's
always a big question as well but if the
bigger question I was wondering and this
is where we got into the whole is d3
coming what's the scale how do you
introduce like a darkness race and stuff
like that was if the pyramid ships were
actually what is being shown on the
radar is more and this is just bad
questioning so you can laugh at me here
in a second but if the pyramid ships are
actually coming as a way to because the
like proximity and time frame when
they're gonna arrive also lines up if
the pyramid ships are in some way
actually Sabbath une coming to maybe
like land on the dread-nots and actually
add the Dreadnought incoming say and
like a fall expansion I was then not
savithri simply as I can put it bring
exclusive so yeah it's something that a
lot of people definitely speculated
about at the beginning when we first saw
them but the appearance of the pyramid
ship on Luna and shadow keep generally
completely and utterly shattered any
even tangible idea that that was the
case you know like it was a very it
seemed pretty clear beforehand and it
was kind of unlikely to be completely
honest but when it came down to it even
though savathun is a trickster and even
though there are definitely places in
which unexpected things can happen in
destiny the relationship between the
hive and the pyramid on Luna basically
nullifies any idea that savathun might
be in the pyramids you know they they're
very much listed as being separate from
them gravity and you know altars of Sora
for example is a great way in which you
can actually see the hive physically
trying to draw power from something that
is not their own in the form of the
nightmares in the form of the darkness
you know so yeah trying to trying to
reach out as the hive and study it has
been one of their long ambitions and
they've only just really been able to do
that because it was only ever activated
by Eris you can actually find a patrol
we're told
says as much to you so yeah not anything
to do with South foon but keep an eye on
her because she's definitely worked with
her machinations to get certain hive
closer to the pyramid and to sort of try
and understand what's going on she in
her own way is trying to become a
constant of the universe right she's
trying to become trickery in a certain
sense and she's also trying to preserve
secrets and in that sense become
secretive herself
I don't know how best to explain it
you'd need to go and read the law books
that you get out of the pit of heresy
it's um you can find it what's the name
of a little book called find this in a
second but yeah it's the one where it's
going off to a male camp and all her
other shenanigans they'll find this in a
second I know I will a pending threat
still and I wouldn't like I wouldn't
doubt that we'll see more of her as time
goes on the thing I would say about
seven fingers I don't even know if it
will ever come to pass that well I
actually face her as a boss in-game you
know because she's too smart to ever let
herself be exposed right do you truly
think that the god of trickery I mean
it's like Loki that's a trickster and he
was thinking treasure like if ya on that
scale so yeah you know I continue ya
know um Inquisition damp by the way
that's the book but ya know even with
all the stuff that she's trying to do
where she's effectively trying to become
immortal in a certain sense there is no
way in which she's going to compromise
herself so easily she'll definitely want
to go out there and acquire resources
that will help her in her quest right
sure what no no no wife eros eros said
she'll let her presence be known we'll
know in the movies
we gotta be smart enough to catch it
that's what ever said that strike yeah
the other thing to know as well is just
the architecture of everything hive
architecture in the architecture of the
darkness is completely different
different no absolutely and even and
even with savathun fleeing into the
portal into the singularity near the end
to the book of Sorrows saying we must
grow apart and become different it's
yeah I don't think there's enough of a
connection
having said that writers have proven me
wrong in the past so we'll see what
happens but yeah I would almost
certainly bet but this is not Sabbath
une this is this is unquestionably
something bigger
this is this yeah this is the darkness
and if if there's any doubt in that
whatsoever it's you know it's got to be
it's got to be placed with something
really solid as a foundation you are you
feeling are you feeling September
expansion II I think it's I think it's
very much strong potential there um I
feel the service season is very much
gonna lead into that if that said I mean
you know it's likely that they'll
actually announce what's going on in
September near the end of this season
right because I mean you can literally
see the pyramid ships approaching the
geeks gonna be up at a certain go to
talk about this race is gonna change me
like that's terrifying yes Dorito Dee
Dee have that like cinematic and then
just like go back and print like I do be
and like put a Dorito fries instead
it'll be hilarious
so here's the question if the darkness
actually is potentially what's coming
for grand-scale
adventure in September that we always
tend to get for big expansion what do
you see as being I don't want to say
filler but what do you how do you
connect and again this is where they
disconnect to the story hopefully
they're getting better how do you
connect this season of the worthy the
Almighty coming in and then they're of
uten which by the way you nailed I
listen to you with your video saying hey
we're gonna shoot these things up in the
air and that's literally what we started
doing on Tuesday yeah
for the great explanation of the
satellite yeah Sara orbit was like you
know that but like how do you go from
this in the almighty to then September
what bridges that gap or what would you
like to see bridge that gap I'd like it
to be the destruction of whichever world
Bungie wants to destroy because I mean
here's the thing right like they clearly
still reaching the closer reaches of the
system by the time that season of the
worthy ends and I think that's an easy
way to cue us into the next expansion
but if they're coming along and Bungie
needs to literally make space there's no
question that this next season will be
about the darkness destroying a world
and the question is do they want to go
ahead and do a story about us trying to
save that world or do they want to go
ahead and potrait utter desperation and
us just trying to run because obviously
when it comes down to it if they go off
to say Titan we have assets in place on
time you know you see an entire whole
load of ships docked by the arcologies
and these aren't just you know random
Junkers from back in the Golden Age that
have seen wear and tear these are actual
you know city skid what's the term it's
not scott fighter it's yeah they're
basically fighters space fighters is
effectively what they are but yeah you
see all of these assets lined up there
and it's like we need to evacuate these
we need to get these white you know we
need to get these things out of here and
it's wise to assume that that's probably
going to be a part of the story is just
evacuate anything off of whatever world
it is that's gonna get destroyed try and
stop the darkness and realize it's
probably not gonna happen you know like
that's gonna be the story and it's gonna
be this first look at the desperation of
what's gonna happen in the system and
you know like the more we talk about the
more I think it's gonna be Titan because
Titan has consistently had these rumors
of destruction going through it yeah
mmm-hmm I'm with you I'm with you no big
like yeah history tends to repeat itself
yeah but yeah it's deep LOI some deep
blood I know I was like I'm the next and
they they even described in the fight
out back in June just saying a season 11
you're gonna want to be there and I mean
they're building it something Crazy's
gonna happen something crazy
well I would say he is I just hope that
and I know we talked about it before
whatever happened I do sit think we we
need to feel a sense of loss like a real
you know scary impending doom thing you
know we need to feel like when we lost
cave we need to feel something you know
I would love for that to be portrayed
cinematically if possible you know and
um you know let them know that you know
it this is this is what we got this is
going to be a serious threat and theme
throughout for a while you know that
would be really cool if they could pull
that off
mm-hmm completely agree the other
question I want to ask then so cuz tying
into the dread-nots and then my brother
and I were talking and joking about the
whole dreaming city and the whole
infinite loop and stuff like of what
that could be empowering if because I
even think you said I recently have
other places but if that is not
empowering savathun which i guess you
were saying we don't actually know it is
what do you think do you think the
Dreaming city like loop when if that
ever comes into play again or is that
stuck in limbo for good or what is it
gonna take to actually get that thing
out of its loop I don't know to be
completely honest like here's the thing
any speculation past or present with
regards to the ability for us to break
the loop that comes from truth to power
which is the main law book attached to
it all
yeah it's don't trust this power any
speculation comes from that is unfounded
purely because of the fact that we're
looking at something which is unproven
which potentially could be deception and
which along with that lies to us very
deliberately throughout the entire like
process of the book and it doesn't just
do so once it does so twice
you know it originally comes to us
claiming to the boost from eros and then
it comes to us claiming after it gets
caught out by our ghost that it's a
thing called Medusa right basically in
artificial intelligence it then
potentially hints that it's coming from
Quarrier which maybe is directly linked
to Salva Thune maybe is not which means
it could be deceiving as it could not be
depends how much autonomy Quarrier
actually has you know like it's stated
that it has some that has the ability to
potentially deceive sever food like Oryx
left as much but it's not 100% clear
that that's the case and then the very
end of the book it says that it's come
from eros again and it's like okay I
just can't trust what you're saying
[Laughter]
exactly exactly and so at the end of the
day any speculation you draw from it
it's really quite dangerous in the
process of it you even go into what is
literally spoken of in the law book as a
vivid hallucination hmm and it just goes
to show like clearly someone is showing
you these things but they're probably
showing them to you very deliberately
you know they're trying to plant ideas
in your head they're trying to do this
and any information we gained from that
book therefore is very suspect so don't
trust truth to power is the number one
thing I'd say and as a result on the
note of the Dreaming cities loop
anything that it says that might break
the loop not guaranteed to be true it's
the best example of this by the way it
talks about how you can get the true
ending to the Dreaming city if I can
shatter thrown a 999 we did that and boy
oh boy oh boy did we get a message from
Sabbath hoon from Bungie yeah no
hopefully being don't trust truth to
power don't trust anything that comes
from anyone even close to the witch
Queen it's a load of yeah it's a
pocketbook Master it's not worth it yes
exactly exactly
oh but actually won't read them
questions just have anything something
um in reference to obviously we know I
don't know Cyrus family but I got to ask
you something in referee
you speak and this has been a point of
contention for me when obviously his
whole history from B 1 then D 2 happens
we have the golfing we have the invasion
and stuff like that and um you know some
information has come out in reference to
his true connection you know to the to
the traveler and lack thereof I call it
false prophet e profiting but you know
through my guy out the tower but this
guy's literally a fraud himself but
anyway moving along but question is like
ok he's go you know obviously we lost
him during the whole you know the red
war and all that stuff but Michael Sheen
is why do you think the tower has not
given someone else the mantle someone
else has not taken up the mantle of
speaker and even your ghost when you
scan his quarters right he says you know
I wonder who the next speaker is going
to be all you know that that Nate you're
like why do you think that is because
ethically d1 was kind of founded he was
a central figure in d1 and now that he's
going I'm actually surprised that what's
your thought process on that so to
understand this I think you need to
understand kind of the governing
structure of the city which is that they
have what is effectively a weird mix of
an executive and a legislative body
right like there is a prime minister of
sorts which is the position of the
speaker holds the speaker is very much
the head of state as best as we can tell
but beyond that the consensus is
something that is both appointed and
kind of elected you know in order for a
faction in particular because the
guardian posts of the Vanguard are set
in the consensus and they're you know
you basically get nominated to the
Vanguard by various different processes
but when it comes to the factions are
very least they'll get ascended because
of their stature right like some of them
are believed to have inappropriate ideas
but they have to have some kind of
civilian backing for them to be assented
in the first place it's all the reason
why the war call gets ascended over
someone like say the simmetry after ly
Sanders faction
the Concord app basically connected the
loop yeah so it's a weird mix of the
principles of an appointed body
alongside something that technically
speaking has some kind of representative
backing to it it's not a true democracy
but by that same token it has elements
of a representative democracy the the
important thing to know about this is
that the main governing body of the city
is still the consensus which is made up
of the major factions involved as well
as the vanguard and the speaker here's
the thing
they've thus far been operating without
the speaker for a very long time and you
can see the first example of this in the
law tab of a sidearm called its piece by
consensus you remember when the first
faction rallies came out yes they had
one item shared among the loophole and
it was this side on piece by consensus
and it talks about how avala opens the
first Vanguard meeting after the red war
has concluded and I think it's it's
either hideo or a Raksha Lyle who says
doesn't the speaker usually do that and
effectively serve Allah says we'll
manage without you know and it's one of
these little saying do we actually need
a speaker the city does not have a
constitution as best I can tell and it
does not have many governing ideals
aside from the fact that the consensus
is they're predominantly to keep balance
between citizens the factions and the
Guardians you know as a result you're
definitely looking looking of a system
that has rules but you're not looking at
a system which has rules that are so set
and so to find that there's say a vices
speaker or an immediate need to search
for a new speaker this is very much an
ad-hoc governmental system so it's yeah
it's weird to look at it like that but
ultimately you're looking at something
that does not have that they're playing
by the seat of their pants to a certain
extent you know like they do have rules
but not so much structures you know you
think in a few hundred years they'd
develop a constitution or something like
that but so the best of my knowledge it
doesn't exist and as a guy who's
literally who literally has degree in
politics I'd be able to spot if
glad for educators I was curious it
doesn't make sense they kind of just
they do they just leave it right there
anything just do the only thing man he's
answering a lot of the questions I've
always wanted to know about it this is
good bad real good stuff you know it
refers to you personally what about all
just in general like obviously we know
your YouTube channel you know this is
your passion above all I love this stuff
you fantastic and um what about a dream
scenario what if what if what if Bungie
approached it said we want you on the
narrative team official job posted
normal would Lord both consider this
this job no and here's why
let's get here's why here's why because
they do not want me and they do not got
me because I am not qualified here's the
big misconception lest I and I'm so glad
that you brought this up because I need
to go ahead and stand in bungees corner
for a second and fight with Ennis Lee
the biggest misconception mm-hmm
everybody sits there and says why won't
you just put myelin and by phone the
narrative tomorrow you tell a better
story people who say that are ignorant
and stupid and I'm gonna tell you why
exactly right now because if you've ever
enjoyed one of our pieces of content you
clearly have not read the story if you
then think that it's a reflection of bad
storytelling by Bungie I will grant you
narrative occasionally has a problem
when it comes to piecing together
cutscenes we've talked about the flow of
continuity not being perfectly there but
when it comes down to the actual law and
the writing you do not want me on the
narrative team because I am nowhere near
as good as so many of the other previous
writers that they have had right I am i
I can barely hold a light I can barely
hold a torch to them so the important
thing and to understand about this is
that all I am doing is I am making the
story more approachable now that is not
necessarily to say that that isn't a
lesson that
could LUN was yes nobody you should be
thus insulting forever you consulted now
by Uighur shortchanging you and your
showing reverence and respect which is
correct but i do want to say that there
is that that the theme and why casuals
sometimes run away from destiny is
because they don't have that
understanding like that you have like
you have that understanding of these
great riders these great stories right
and you you adapted in such a way that
it's easy to understand for the casual
gamer who doesn't know what's going on
so what about like a consultant role it
referenced in it I consider a consultant
role but beyond all of just that it's
you know I I sit there and I like to
think that as my position in the
community it's not something that I at
least with Bungie it's not something
where it necessarily asked for it to
become part of a job you know cuz that
creates a conflict of interests but I'm
consulting them on something where the
story goes or a way in which they can
deliver the story that then directly
conflicts with the fact that I am trying
to tell it you know I'm trying to for
the best but for the best part when it
comes down to it I will keep spoilers
away from my audience like it's me
trying to hide kids from the plague I
respect like you know when it comes down
to it it's it's it's one thing to
understand what's happening it's another
thing entirely to know where it's going
but and I try to limit that second part
where appropriate and like yeah sure
there are going to be moments where in
order to prevent my audience being
spoiled I will deliberately spoil myself
and I'll make sure that we know what to
look for like it's actually something
but my mods do really well in the
discord server that we run we have
basically embargoes on any spoiler ish
kind of details and I will arm them with
the knowledge that they need to cut that
stuff out as quickly as they can so that
we don't spoil the average passerby but
ultimately there you know it all speaks
to the bigger responsibility of being a
part of this community like yeah sure
it's my job I make money from it it's
it's how I pay my bills and it's how I
pay my taxes like totally fair enough
and a consulting job would be most
certainly an honor and you know even
something where similar to what Milan
did you know where he sat down with them
and made a grimoire like I think
opportunities like that a we have
potential but my biggest priority is to
always make sure that I'm serving the
community well and that there is no
conflict of interest and when it comes
to being on the narrative team
definitely the case when it comes to
consulting job probably the case um and
Bildad kind of ruin your fun - I feel
yeah kind of and this this is this leads
back into the last thing I really like
my job like my job has some stressful
moments granted and I work really really
hard but I don't know if I trade this
job for anything you know like I have an
amazing career path that I've you know
trotted along thus far and I have no
idea where it goes from now but you know
it's been the craziest opportunity of my
entire life
and you know I owe a lot of it to the
fact that Bungie has a fantastic
narrative team you know like Derek you
know there's clearly a lot of people
coming along nearly 800,000 people kind
of by subscription by proxy are saying
yeah we think that this story would you
like to know more as the god what's it
called god yeah whatever point point
being like everybody is invested and I
want to make sure that I take that kind
of responsibility forward and if that
means that I get offered a job I think
about that very carefully because I
would like much as it is very much my
ability to make money that would end up
being impacted by that possibly
positively positively negatively there
is a bigger thing that I want to always
consider and that is going to be the
community no matter what comes up you
know like at the end of the day it is
yes Starship Troopers by the way Thank
You commander
um but yeah no like responsibilities if
the community is up
really big thing for me so first that's
kind of where I sit on that one along
with along with the fact that again I'm
just not qualified for that stuff like
I'm a good I'm a good orator and I'm a
good storyteller in terms of my ability
to take someone's narrative and to make
it digestible I am not someone you want
writing that narrative I am not someone
you want writing it because I'm untested
I have not made my own stories thus far
I have never made a story much as some
people say that I literally write the
law and people say being like what are
you doing like that still astounds me
that people get that misconception for
point being no yeah there's a bigger
there's a bigger responsibility there
and I'm not the kind of guy that you
won't write in the story anyway you want
someone qualified you know they've had
great writers in the past
Zef Dickinson Josh Shaw No Mallory's I
can't I forget her name but yeah Z is
the shorthand for like there's so many
fantastic writers on the team who have
come and gone and who have done great
things for the world of destiny and yeah
III do not stand among their ranks and
rightly so because I'm nowhere near as
talented as they are calling you the
chronicler my brother is like if
approached by audible would you
narrating books mm yes that'll give you
a constant sauce it was as long as the
pay as good as long as the pay is good
yeah that's right make sure you check is
right so amazing voice over you know
Sade SP themes and in great story oughta
be basic I think that'll be cool dude
absolutely a couple of questions there's
one I did want though
so shout out to WT Prescott as well
would have was good he said with the
darkness ships coming close to the grave
of the first fleet he said do you have
any speculation of what asset Mara Sauve
asked the nine to move there
I honestly have no idea but I'm glad
that people remember that it nearly am
because it there's potential for it to
play a really big part in the future
story and there's a few assets that the
nine have out in that vicinity generally
if anybody has read I believe it's the
gateway I need to double check on it but
again in stolen intelligence there is
talk of how the nine basically
commandeered a portal and used it to
create life and this because the nine
are basically dark matter incarnate
right and then they attempted to commune
with us by sending through first
just a few protein molecules then a
single-celled organism that died
immediately then you know something
which effectively was a larger
multicellular organism that again died
immediately then something which had
lungs but nowhere to create oxygen which
was metabolized into a blood stream and
they were slowly trying to get better
and better and better at creating life
and you know there's all sorts of other
crazy stuff out there in the reef like
if the grave of the First Fleet and all
these other different places yeah they
they're potentially filled with
opportunities for weird story moments
like that like yeah there's this cool
things out there you just need to go
ahead and search for them he's like the
last lorry entry on bungie.net is the
ominous parting of Osiris insane he said
that Toland has has been left unchecked
for too long what do you think is
causing concern for Osiris to mention
that oh well I'm with I'm with Osiris on
this one I'm perpetually concerned about
Toland I've been concerned about tollens
since the end of taking King yes right
like I've sat there and always known
that the man has an affinity for
darkness and with the darkness
approaching the possibility of Toland
trying to commune with it directly is
very high and Toland was a guardian at
one point even though he was exiled for
madness so you know that's a fact very
intelligence beyond all of that though
there is there is the potential big hive
problem that's going on which I don't
think is one that will rear
it's head-but Toland has um continuously
told us you know congratulations you've
killed the king but you need to go into
his throne world to kill him
that will leave a vacancy within the
hive majesty
it will mean that their monarchy is
unfulfilled do let me know if a vacancy
opens up so he's you know he's maybe
that's a joke maybe it's not but he's
constantly being kind of posturing for
this place even has even though it's
small and kind of pathetic a small
outcropping in the ascendant realm he's
carved out his own sword space there so
it's very clear that he's getting better
at being a practitioner of the darkness
and with all of that there is a big a
problem that comes with it because he
effectively will stop caring about our
struggle when he has the avenue to
become powerful enough to fill those
spaces inside through so if he ever
becomes more powerful I think he could
be the Joker to our Batman mm-hmm which
I think it is a fantastic narrative arc
the Bungie could oh oh yeah by but yeah
um what I'd love to see as well and this
maybe is a way in which they could
potentially approach a Sabbath oon story
in which she is mortal yeah have Toland
like throw down against Sabbath une with
some clearing himself like if there's
somebody who could be a wild-card in
that I think that it could be Toland mm
yeah speaking of wildcards oh I gotta
he's got me thinking Calais and I mean
he's just popping up here and there and
uh you know we had the Ray we had the
the the the the gotcha moment at the end
of the right here at the lavandula vibin
you know but um you know and since then
he's been on the fringes still you know
communicating with us you know wanting
us to grow fat from strength and you
know then we had the chronic on and all
this stuff so like you know he's an
interesting bigger and I am very curious
to see how Bungie handles him moving
forward like you know what's your
thoughts on Calais for the future of
death
like his role on thing that's very
interesting question I think that it's
gonna tie into his daughter and the
story of the Cabal overall if anybody
has grinded out enough metals they may
already have the heir apparent heavy
machine-gun and if you've read the law
tab on that you've basically seen his
daughter Keitel who rebelled against him
and exiled him during the midnight coup
along with why is everybody exhaling
what is going on in the college but like
they literally they literally had a
grand coup it's well the reason why it's
such a big event you know midnight who's
not just had cannon it's the thing that
happened so he's goal and maybe eight
other conspirators I think it is
basically got together and these are
conspirators through all sorts of
different levels of government and some
of them not like analysis random tea
merchant that was found at the end of
one of the streets that he loved to
stroll through the you know capital
total battle that's that you know that
was one of the conspirators his own
daughter was a conspirator he had a good
general Primus of all legions who muna
Roth was one of the conspirators goal on
the console were two of the conspirators
you know like I feel like it's also it's
the Imperial dreamer is she was a scion
who basically led them all communicate
yeah like these are all conspirators and
they all excelled callous and as a
result the Cabal have been sort of left
in this weird split you know you have
Calais who went on his diaspora with his
followers and his attendants and then
came back and has started gaining
followers from the Cabal that have
slowly parted ways with the red Legion
and then you have the rest of the Empire
which seemingly is still ruled by the
red Legion has influence from title at
this point because she's one of the only
standing likely heirs to the entire
thing you know she's calluses air even
if she didn't go on to the midnight coup
and she stood with Gaul which means that
she is the likely ruler now that Ghul is
dead so I think that's where the story
is going I think that those two
characters will come to a head and then
we will have to deal with the Cabal as a
whole you know I feel like just in the
same way that I feel mythrax will be one
of the characters that is a capstone to
that racist story I think that title and
Calais will be Capstone's to the cabal's
story as a race interesting interesting
storyline just I just very there's a lot
of threads there and I'm very curious to
see where that interested me but you
gotta eat oh it's like just when it
comes to like the races as we're talking
about the Cabal it's like I feel like
the scale of the races and some of the
stories we've had it always kind of
jumps around and when we go and you're
talking about myth wrecks for a capstone
for a you know a fallen story arc or
something that could be and that you
have cabal getting a little bigger if
you were to rank like the threat level
or grand scale of each race like I don't
want to speculate so how would you rank
the races that we're facing
obviously darkness being question mark
number five where would you put them on
either threat level or how big these
stores can be because if we have the
darkness coming in you know potentially
in like six weeks they're gonna be here
and you know a few fortnight's and then
they show up then if you take this big
departure to this you know more you know
Terran level fallen storyline
it looks like jumping between those but
I was still just curious like where do
you rank the threats of each race how do
you put them in scale I don't know if
they would rank them in terms of threat
but I would rank them in terms of power
and the reason I say that is because
races like the Fallen may actually end
up being allied with us in the end you
know especially with me Thrax in the
house of light there's a lot of
implications that that's where the story
is going with her ex appears to be sort
of if me throw axes to the arbiter as
the elites yeah raid it out to compare
halo and destiny uh but but yeah um when
it comes down to it fallen are
definitely the least powerful unless
mythrax is somehow chosen by the
traveler which implies that he could
gain some of the powers of the light but
until that happens they're very much
bottom of the barrel they are scavengers
there
hang on following up after that you have
to rate it by causal or power causal
ability and following that there's
definitely the Cabal there were a mighty
star Empire but they're also a failed
state to a certain extent now we've
killed lots of their leaders they have
consistent command problems because of
that
whether it's us killing goal or Valco or
battle we're like yeah you know whether
it's coggan from the insight ominous we
have consistently gone through and
killed their commanders and as a result
we just keep on lopping off the heads of
this Hydra and it feels like it's
genuinely starting to run out of heads
you know Callison kai clawed becoming
the figureheads of each respective
faction it looks like and with all of
that there's this big move now towards
what do they do next and at the moment
it feels like they're stagnant and
that's very much deliberate on the part
of the storytelling for the sake of
trying to set them up for the next big
encounter with them I think after that
this effects they are not a para causal
threat late for hive or the darkness or
the light but they are most certainly
still dangerous they have you know
abilities of prediction that sometimes
are able to surpass darkness and light
and we saw that in casts of a cyrus you
know the the vex that you found out on
Mercury were able to actually find a
future timeline that they were then
trending the world towards in which they
were then able to destroy both the light
and the darkness and there's even a law
tab of something that makes commentary
saying that that fate is worse than even
being ruled by darkness because wasn't
darkness despises life generally it
still admits the permission of strong
life you know some life does persist
with the vex it's the case of only the
pattern can exist and so they're a
constant existential threat but as the
vault of glass will always say Guardians
make their own fate so you know we are
constantly able to overpower them power
causality is the key and that's the
reason why after before the darkness the
hive will always be the number one
threat that we need to take a look at
like darkness will always be top of the
top of the pile but before we face
darkness that
but to slot will always be the hive you
know there they have the ability to use
dark powers they have consistently been
able to use power causality to their
advantage
the taking King was a literal God none
of this pretend nonsense from the phone
splices none of this stuff where it was
just you know a God in metaphor alone no
crota and Oryx in a very literal sense
were gods and we have faced nothing
quite like them since this wall like the
darkness will honestly be the biggest
test that we have I think since Oryx in
terms of a narrative sense you know like
yeah everybody can go ahead and talk
about how riven tricked Oryx but
ultimately her powers were you know it
kind of pales in comparison to accolades
Oryx right like this is this this is a
guy who literally brought with him an
entire new enemy race in gameplay terms
and he gained that enemy race by killing
a god and stealing its power and the
secret of how to create that and then
communing with the darkness you know he
still may not be quote completely gone
right because thought his heart is not
completely found or something like that
with it depends on what's happened to
the touch of malice yeah but as we shall
see we shall see I mean we can probably
do this forever which is not fair to a
free-to-use not credible so it's like
just asking forever but no it was like
as for what's going on in the world of
destiny itself of course we know you're
like the lore master but you'll kick the
crap out of a lot of people in crucible
and raid with the best of them so you
play the game as much as you know more
than most of us about it which is
impressive and obviously we know we got
a pretty big 12 this week with relation
to like trials and stuff like that but
we did have the big event kickoff this
week so I just kind of wanted to see
about the whole Guardian games
activities if you guys have playing it
if you got the machine gun already if
you did then you grind it like hell to
just kind of curious how your thoughts
of Guardian games have been for both you
guys this week of everything we've been
playing
I mean we got asked by first you got
steamed yes Gillian you could you go you
got at least it's it's a light event
what I like I like the thought behind I
like the you know because let's be real
destiny has always had this intrinsic
little ribbing and beeping with each
other from like from a class but you
know we do it all the time you don't say
like I get excited you're wrong cuz I
finally have a warlock what by my side
it's just it's always been that you know
and and and I call it that last Fri
right you know why you choose that
character you know I think beautifully
explained why can we kind of share
similar things for me I've always taken
god I like the warrior or the British
clash and most but it was something
about the character creation screen and
seeing that warlock and holding the ball
of power energy whatever he's commanding
and it kind of grew it grew to may
gravitate towards that so I like the
idea of this I think it's it's cool it's
almost like an Olympic feel each day you
get your put in your web you know you
put in your medals you know now they
have enough to do a lot of very things
which is you know which is cool but um
you know at the end of the day some I
think are a little too specific because
I think shout out to the two men of
hungers being that's not that doesn't
work I was like you know it's just one
of those things that like um you know I
like sometimes to just stay in a
subclass here and there but now I'm like
switching all the time we're gonna be
anomaly I gotta be this just to get
certain things done I think the spirit
of it is cool you know what's a fun
little thing so first of all I gotta
give them props on this shout-out to the
class I because finally that finally we
have a bond the pops dude yes like six
years we have something like ornate and
boombastic that we could feel proud not
this little circle around the arm and
nothing else going on like this is what
I want to see you know and I hope this
is the direction it moving forward
but uh yeah look I know what it is it's
it's a like a filler event but I do
think it is on the spirit of it is fun
to check in every day you know Titans
right now killing it you know okay I
shut off you guys kill the hunters have
the big lead initially look I I will
simply say this man I'm okay with Titans
winning and warlocks coming second as
long as we collectively that's a
coalition and make sure the hunters come
third
the hunters winner I like the word
choice of coalition there I appreciate
like I said I want to get that um I want
to get that gun I saw some videos don't
have big shout out the back is shut up
the cross watch their video it looks
really good once it's charged up and um
you get that little arc shield you know
kind of going on behind it so um you
know I'm looking forward to getting that
to me this is you know fill a contact
between season stuff I'm not gonna get
too crazy but wait wait wait bye mm-hmm
I think that the spirit of the
competition is good I think that when it
comes down to it like I've seen a lot of
people very fondly embracing their class
and yeah sure we talked about like
coalition against the hunters but it's
all in good faith like you talked about
like friendly ribbing between classes
yeah yeah like we're all basically
jostling for position and that's fine
like it happens that's all good
I think the problem with it ultimately
comes down to the fact that it is just
basically do seven bounties every day
and that's kind of it like yeah yeah
sure well there's a few there's a few
cool trance in there the exotic is
unquestionably gonna be really nice to
get the class items I've heard good
things about them the ghosts oh my god I
love my newest the lion is decent but
the flying gold bird is that is
immaculately done so good yes so just
one chefs kiss and the perks on them you
got both guiding light and speed demon
the only thing you needed is a combo
detector but at least you've got ghosts
that people are gonna use to which is
yeah absolutely
and you know like I feel as though if
they really want to do this they need to
go ahead and give an event like this a
bit more flesh so to speak it's like I'm
fine with the concept behind having a
rivalry between classes and then you
know having this repeat year on year I
think that if you're gonna go ahead and
do this again it's gonna have more to it
I do also understand and this is
something I think can be said about the
entire season their season is lighter oh
I think that from a perspective of
development and considering what's going
on I think that that's okay
and I wanna I don't want to go ahead and
give Maji a free pass on stuff right
because again like we should hold people
to high standards there's something
doesn't fit if something doesn't work
that's okay but if this means that the
team has more time to develop the next
big expansion that's coming along
and if generally speaking it provides
people with a season where they can put
the game down and take a break from it
for a bit I think that's actually really
good and really healthy like don't get
me wrong I still play destiny a lot and
I grind but most of the time I have one
season that I sort of take everything on
the back burner from you that was season
of dawn that was last season you know I
barely got to you know yeah I barely got
to season ranked 200 on my past and I
grinded out those levels just so I could
get the fry like I I lost sector Goblin
to my way through that you know I went
the full gremlin for our end of the
season and then I just got my like
hundred levels so I could get my 20
power on the artifact and I was done
like you know I didn't play a lot I took
a nice break during the winter time I
didn't make as many videos on things and
it wasn't exactly like a full holiday
but it was one of those moments where I
was able to not burn out on the game
right that was really important you know
so I I sat there and I was like yeah I'm
gonna take this moment to cool down just
let things go and then I'll be refreshed
and ready for the next season hey you
know for some people that's actually a
really healthy choice is stepping away
like I think this is also a mentality
people need to get into mm-hmm it's nice
to know that we can come back to destiny
every week and there's probably
something new that's really good but I
think people also need to grapple with
the idea that it's okay to step away
occasionally like yeah sure if content
in the game sucks and that's bad right
like the state of trials right now is
yeah and the fact that we're you know
like yeah the Serb Charles is pretty
unacceptable in the fact that that
content delivery is basically kind of
fallen on its face it is really sad to
see but by that same token you know if
we're looking at content generally we
don't want this thing to completely
consume our lives all the time
like we do want moments where we can put
this down and like yeah I I get the need
for content I get that it's irritating
sometimes when you see people screaming
that the game is dead but at the end of
the day light from that dead there's
there's a moral need for end points in
games I believe there is a moral need
for people to be able to put a game down
and say I've had my fill for the moment
and walk away and do something else you
know and well that's another game or
whether it's just spending time of your
family whether it's reading a good book
whether it's making yourself some good
food whether it's going to sleep you
have end points and having something
that is all-consuming is good sometimes
but not all the time
as with anything it is about moderation
you know it's really neat that we can
come back and find something new
practically every week that's pretty
damn cool I love that but it shouldn't
feel like it sure that's the whole thing
I'm reading the crystal Hydralisk a week
reckons I'm very weak to just what the
like getting to take a break and the way
the seasons are built and stuff it's
like if yours was dawn mine's been
somewhat this season as well but I feel
like some of these seasons have people
feel like oh I just got to play it all
the time as a lot of them are saying in
the chat it's like Prescott it's like
it's you you were not obligated to play
this game even though sometimes we feel
like it and it's kind of nice though I
think people are starting to get these
revelations and somebody
seasons that like this is a lighter cool
I can go I can breathe and go see the
outdoors for a minute which is something
we all definitely have to do exactly
dude like here's the thing I literally
do this stuff as part of my job no one
else unless they're like a content
creator of some stripe should feel
obligated to throw as many hours into
this as I do you know like I play trials
every week so I can get my one win so
that I can make sure that I'm still
getting the log book sometimes I'll go
flawless sometimes I'll get some wins
like that's always cool I love that but
you know I'm still obligated to go ahead
and play for some base reasons and you
know that's about it man I mean yeah
Guardian games they did say one thing
about Guardian games just if you guys
are trying to go for your class that the
final week is gonna be double points so
if the you know crayon eaters do hold it
up for a little while don't slack off in
the final week just say ah but trials
yeah that was the big piece of they said
trials and tribulations was the main
topic of they've got different things
they're gonna talk about as they go
through versus the seasonal model and
stuff like that so they've got some
pretty important Wobs coming up so
definitely stay tuned in coming weeks
this one they talk about the problems
that are facing trials and they've been
listening to community feedback and a
lot of people are like hey this that the
other so many lists of things like you
guys aren't doing anything they are
listening I guarantee the community gate
managers or gathering stuff every day
taking of the teams trying to cross this
stuff just nothing happens overnight
development cycles take time and of
course we know between being locked at
home and working on six other things
they're slightly busy but they said the
main three problems in trials of Osiris
itself are as follows and they've
actually proposed a couple of solutions
so I want to kind of take it one at a
time with each of you guys so the
problem first one is the token reward
incentives players incentivizes players
to farm three wins and reset the card
solution in season 11 coming next but it
is six weeks away we're playing and
creating token payout milestones at
three five and seven
wins that give successfully larger
chunks chunks of tokens bonus tokens
passage should increase these payouts
and on flawless run it will generate a
significant token payout ooh
so first thoughts on that between both
of y'all want some numbers on that
because I want to know that it's gonna
be enough you know like if people are
going flawless with that stuff that's
great I'd love it if teams would
actually go to their 7 wins but we need
to know if the maths is there because
otherwise it's they need to take into
account that people will get to tokens
by bounty right over peaceful and those
repeats poles can be accomplished very
fast so unless you're looking at say
maybe 20 tokens for this payout for tier
3 and then successively more and more
and more yeah you still have the same
problem when you you know like the
flawless chest [ __ ] of like what at what
numbers would you like to see what's
that what's a good number for you
oh dude from the floss one I'd say 80 to
100 tokens there really I'm kidding yeah
you get 5 Legendary's out of that from
saint-14
that'll be aight i mean you know
consider that used to have all of the
others from the previous ones let's say
it's 20 40 60 from 3 5 and 7
respectively you know you're looking at
a significant all of stuff there and it
will definitely feel like your time has
been invested similarly take a look at
what happens in nightfalls dude like you
have legendaries dropping all the
freaking time in night falls and you'll
come out of that you know you'll only
have your one pinnacle or your one
powerful but you've got all of these
random legendaries that you've done
you've probably gotten a lot of tokens
that you can turn into Savola and if
you're gonna go ahead and give the
parity of tokens yeah you then probably
have a similar number of uh you should
probably have a similar mer of weapons
or a piece of armor that you could get
and beyond all of that with a single
activity with a very limited set of
stuff it means that everybody gets to
share a bit in the wealth you know right
so there is less of a stress of trying
to go ahead and get that one roll you
know like right if if you give everyone
the ability to jump in and grab that
stuff more effectively they think
it helps the problem overall admittedly
more people are gonna have their gold
role astral horizons right but by that
same token when they have their God role
astral horizons it also takes the
farmers out of the queue so it does it
does solidify the measure around strong
weapons again but you know you're still
looking at something where you don't
have people like being stopped into
oblivion by this yes stop I don't want
it only three win guys yeah I'll sit
there and I'll say this I think that my
like 80 to 100 tokens is very optimistic
like that's incredibly optimistic and I
think it'll probably something closer to
50 but they need to get those numbers
right is the immunity point you know
like if they don't have enough
incentives from all of that then you
have a big problem completely agree you
gotta incentivize it
yeah ask to be incentive but going the
length of the car and that nice payout
completely agree it's like the time
investment too and you compare that you
can run night falls really fast in
comparison to a full trials card good
bad or otherwise whether you go 7 or you
know you get the mercy and you go 8-8
personal matches just loading into them
alone takes a little while for
matchmaking and night falls you can do
over and over and over and if you farm
those not as fast as a crucible match
for some if they're good so no it's like
it needs it needs the parity between the
two to be a lot more even so hopefully
they know one of the highest it to which
I think we'll talk about think yeah yep
problem 2 trials is unrewarding for
players stuck at one to two wins
resolution create a weekly bounty that
encourages participation each weekend
and does not require match wins win
redeemed the bounty will reward the same
item that comes from the three wind
passage unlocking the Engram for a
purchase that week did someone say oh
gee you seem excited cockney you know do
you ever dependence did someone say
bounty I'll be I just remember say
talking about this in using expression
if it wasn't broke did I said it don't
fix it and this was literally what I was
so happy like you have no idea because
again and by we had talked about it last
night's work which was you
one of the things that really
incentivizes someone who is either a
casual or not the greatest people cuz
I'm not I'm not I'm very average but I
remember playing d1 and yeah I would get
go to you know Vance and I you get those
bounties from him and a lot of it was
more about getting kills as a unified
team or individual things that just made
you participate that didn't wasn't
required for win right and I'll never
forget when I got my first doctrine of
passing night and that helped me so much
by it it really gave me conference that
I can compete I had a kind of metal
weapon got a semi-decent role and these
are the things you have to incentivize
the guys who are not the greatest EVPs a
hardcore but if just by that by their
participation their incentivize okay
just to continue to keep going there's
no one likes to get up stomp one time
before three wins and then you can't
even catch the tokens in and do anything
with it so to me this is huge I really
like that they bring in the bounty
system back in addition to it and I want
your thoughts on the whole thing you
know what you see in this you know
second point as far as their problem in
their solution to it yeah I think they
need one more bounty
I think they should have one which is
and both of them should be guaranteed
pieces of gear by the way or very least
should unlock that potential piece I
think they should have a bounty that not
only does what they're going to do but
also a bounty that Awards something for
three wins but not three wins
back-to-back or three wins on the same
card just three wins okay you can get
them at any point in time you know I
think that's an important one not only
because it adds another multiplier and
something that helps you get past that
first hurdle and awards you for putting
in the time of three wins worth of games
but also if you see that you have won
three times throughout the card and even
or throughout your cards at that point
even if sometimes you've lost it's an
incentive to say like hey you can do
this you can get three wins and you know
what you probably could get them
back-to-back or at very least on the
same card like it's not
possible it can't happen so I feel like
that's another important one that they
should add and I think the other
division they need to do is make one of
those worth Armour and one of them worth
weapons
you know subdivide it so that you've got
an equal ability to access the pool of
loot every week about a return oh no I
mean that's that's the type of thing for
me whether I mean as you said the three
wins is good you could also be a
cumulation of like rounds because you
may not win the full match if but if you
actually pull out some rounds that you
can eventually get there is would be it
just gives incentive for the player base
to attempt it even for a lot bigger
skill skill range of like hey the upper
echelons in there well maybe I can jump
in we get this one match we put it
together even unfortunately for them it
might be the ones where they put their
supers together and get a chance to let
go off they can still have that way to
get in their practice face those more
higher skilled players and just get a
chance to get in there more frequently
so the bounties I would I'm very happy
to see those coming back we've talked
about them of course so it's not
anything but yeah either wins rounds
however they do it then incentivization
for a much broader skill range to get
some benefit from it is huge good to see
next problem
trials feels unrewarding compared to
other in-game activities we kind of
touched on this but in solution inject
more chances to earn master working
materials from trials master working
slash infusion materials will come from
three five seven win payouts in Season
eleven we're also possibly looking at
adding new material focused farming card
in season 12 she's a good idea like I
guess very a very good idea because if
people want to run nightfalls constantly
over and over again for the chance at
not just the exotics but also the
ascendant shards the enhancement prisons
and lower tier ones like the 979 Falls
the enhancement cause why not make a
cart that also incentivizes that there
are players who will just play it
casually and then there are PvP guards
who run it all week and get their first
floors in the first run no matter what
and then they just want to go back into
the playlist and play over and over and
over
give them a reparative reward I'm really
glad to see them do this I think what
they should do is they should tie
ascendant chance to seven wins instead
of two flawless because if you complete
a grandmaster nightfall you will get
shards every time you do it if you get
flawless you get one shot and I think
that that will then help create parity
and also its better reward even if you
don't go flawless which helps like the
population of the playlist I agree I'm
with you on this base 1% good instead of
better I'm in career everybody what you
got gay oh no I mean you pretty much
nailed it just the fact they know that
yeah it's like I mean incentivizing the
endgame with more things we have mass
working and of course there's a
discussion of other things which we'll
get to here in a second as he says hmm
for example you may be asking what about
adept weapons we're currently
investigating a new form of flawless
award weapons in for a future season
this is where it says a future season so
big question there they might not have
the same name but these weapons would
have some differences in order to set
them apart right now we are currently
looking at giving these weapons the
ability to replace the weapon mod slot
within a depth mod slot name a change
that can accept custom-built mods in
addition to the normal list of weapon
mods all of this is subject to changes
would continue to develop but would want
to give you an early look will show more
details in the future so just the
concept of an adept weapon mod slot a
way to set it up what do you guys do you
guys like that versus the intrinsic perk
of say adept weapons having celerity
just intrinsically on it which way would
you like to see it to go what do you
think um
I think this is why um obviously the
community has been screaming at that
weapons for the longest we need more
flawless
you know incentive that was again
something that existed in d1 it was a
level of you know proving to the the
hardcore you know you have something
special you've accomplished something
and it incentivize you to go for the 7
which is them you know not let you
penalize and gang up on a 3-1 guy no for
the mod thing this is interest I like it
I just want to see
if there will be more mods aside from
like celerity right the celerity we
agree I believe that it's a great perk
that should have probably been
intrinsically on the weapon as an adept
weapon right there's something that you
will only use in trials you have a
crease handling blah blah blah whatever
the perk gives you that is specific to
the mold what I want to know is if you
remember in d1 you know there were
certain trials armor pieces that maybe
helped to revive a little quicker you
know they were certain other little
things that were very trial specific and
I want to know if they're going to
expand expand upon that with other mods
that are trial trial specific that you
may be able to interchange I'm very
curious to see how they Hamlet maybe a
secretive right now for the reason but
the potential I want to know where by
where you are with this because um I
just feel the community the hardcore
community we needed it at that weapons
and we need something special and I
think they may have some potential with
this mod slap thing wait yeah I think
the celerity as it stands whilst it's
built really well for the idea of it
being on the lost weapon I wonder
whether it might be too strong to become
intrinsic my thought though when it
comes down to this is all about whatever
they do will it be something that
doesn't completely gate off lower levels
of the crucible skill curve from getting
flawless in the first place you know
like I think that's my only real concern
I love the concept of a mod slot for it
though I think that it allows them a lot
of flexibility as far as design is
concerned it means that if a mod is too
strong one season there's potential to
phase it out next season or IB just make
it so that future adept weapons won't
roll with that and if it falls out of
the meta the mod will also fall out with
it like it's a very interesting idea and
how it ties in potentially could work
but I really want to see how they expand
on that and also the whole thing of the
mod falling out of flavor that season
might not apply if you can just apply it
to any weapon so it's a big question
mark for me I'd be interested to see
what it looks like before I render final
judge
but yeah I mean you know we'll see what
happens but before you pass what about a
debt weapons the concept in general are
you bro are you against do you feel it
gives too much of an advantage to a
flawless I I think I think the the idea
of celerity on adept weapons is maybe it
needs to be tuned down just a little but
you know I think that it fits for
purpose with regards to what you're
doing for trials because again it isn't
poke that will only activate when you're
the last Guardian standing beyond all of
that I think there is a bigger point to
be made which is that adept weapons
generally are and were still a good idea
you know having snapshot on adaptations
was really really nice having even just
I think it was a buff term ability yeah
and one of the things that you had for
some of the guns you know like little
stat bumps like that worked and it was
also a different aesthetic which showed
that you've gone gold you know like I
had my I had my pulse rifle but I got
them from the lighthouse on my first run
I mean destiny well not okay first run
in year three of Destiny one which I
still loved the blind perdition and it
was an amazing pulse was so beautiful
especially of that lovely gold skin so
yeah XE backs you know little things
like that those are the things that I'd
look for I don't know if I'd want there
to be huge differences between them like
faster reload speed or just little
little stat boost as you're saying to be
here's the normal version okay you went
flawless this one is like the optimal
version but if you're due to duking it
out with somebody you still probably
could win either way if you've got the
skill to do it I'd say if you gave a
small bump to handling it would be a
really good one like a good player is
gonna be able to make a lot out of a
small bump to handling when somebody who
is say less skilled is not gonna
necessarily notice the difference and it
you know it's not gonna set the weapons
apart too much like with some weapons it
does make a huge difference like low
handling or Imperial the Korea's why it
doesn't get used over something like say
an astral horizon but you know the
bringing that up just a little bit
giving in a tiny pinch more gives you
the potential for that weapon to edge
out against others particularly at lower
potentials you know like lower ends of
the card where you might be able to make
that work a little better it's something
where you might not notice it but when
you get to the really high tier of the
card and where everything matters like
if that's gonna be really good to have
so yeah I don't know little things but
I'm definitely not the most educated
opinion on this dropping gems I mean
that's the big three problems I mean
they talk about a depth of weapons
coming to the future now so the other
topic if you guys haven't could tell is
Jesus was the huge thing and they talked
about this I thought that guy had a
fully automatic whisper of the worm that
was totally just finals the ship that
shut down one day man anyway so they
have stated since January cheating is up
about 50% which is a huge number and
they expected it to get a bump in trials
due to obviously people wanted to get
through all the toughest people to get
give the rewards but they said they have
done some things the valve integration
the steam data relay has helped DDoS
attacks on Steam which honestly you
don't hear about that much but
unfortunately as those fell away we
found other problems which have quite
abundance they give a couple stats as
well they said the banhammer has not
been idle season of the worthy since
season a little worthy launched they
have more than tripled to the number of
punishments from 656 in previous weeks
to banning over 2,100 people per week
which is a lot mmm that's still doesn't
sound like that big of a number when you
see that the whatever mod that people
were downloading for the cheating was
downloaded like 300,000 times or
something yes so it just doesn't sound
like as big of a number not saying they
need to just ban everybody but then
those two numbers don't seem to
correlate that well no they mentioned on
PC where most shooting occurs
unsurprisingly of course they saying
memory poking attacks were like infinite
ammo ability energy infinite respawns
teleporters which is nice to see them
literally list all of this stuff because
they are like they're aware like aimbots
wall hiking lag switching and all the
stuff I just listed to infinite ammo
abilities respawns teleports they're
aware of it at least they list it all
here as things that they're working on
now aimbots wall hex they have pret they
have a plan but they're not saying
anything about it they mentioned the way
the game is actually built to optimize
certain things especially for the memory
poking stuff as they're saying for it
being a PDE game brings in issues when
it comes to pvp things working that
hybrid infrastructure they would talk
about yep I think if it started to yeah
so that Devlin brings into something so
there's a subtle point we've struggled
to convey over the years and I did want
to mention this we do have servers
hosting every match but in our hosting
model those servers don't have complete
authority over the game simulation to
prevent all of these sorts of attacks
naturally this makes it more difficult
but not impossible to mitigate these
attacks so I think that's probably one
of the first times they've almost
clarified that as well just to say that
there's there's something involved and
again that's probably why stadia is like
the safest place to play right now
because you can't touch it it's like you
know it's like the MC Hammer of crucible
yeah but you've got lag switching as
well and then they say consoles you've
got ddossing trials and consoles as well
so the two big things are obviously
people have made these software things
that will work on PC and DDoS things
still being a thing in trials they're
trying but I just I mean with the status
of trials with this large
acknowledgement being a good thing just
kind of wanted to get your thoughts of
if you've even experienced it have you
even seen any yet and then also with the
stuff that they're working towards just
kind of your thoughts on will get to the
policies here in a second but just the
acknowledgement as this as in have I
seen cheating or have I seen the
response to shooting no have you seen
have you actually experienced it
firsthand yet oh you think every every
every week past first week of trials
I've experienced cheating of some kind
last week I was doing trials with fun
police
on
police yeah fun police yeah Fumi is a
great guy but we ran into cheaters on
our seventh game we'd be oh well thank
Haley but still still you know like that
was one of the lighter weeks for
cheating and some people say that that
card of ours was incredibly lucky
because they've run into them all week
long like I think the real high fret was
unquestionably widow's core john bull
hacking an aimbot on widows when you
have snipers is such a crazy huge
advantage it's ridiculous and that's
before you even mention all of the
memory poking stuff that they talk about
where you can just you know fly around
using one thousand voices and have
infinite respawns you know like yeah
that's like I've I luckily never run
into that but god it's actually no I say
that I've run into the infinite respawns
once but it wasn't in trials it was in
comp I've never run into the you know
funnel ship following oh yeah a
compilation of all the cheaters and it's
sad that there are that many different
types of things happening yeah long
story short it is rampant it's so grand
it's stuff like it it's like a curse
dude it's a disease when you get like
everybody's talking about oh man I just
really want to get to three wins well
when you get past three wins you will
see the cheaters you will see them on
mass like you think if you think that
this boy is just way too cracked with a
sniper rifle yes
he's probably way too cracked the sniper
rifle CO 2 trials report and I guarantee
you most of the time they're gonna have
a 100 to 90 cent accuracy with our VOCA
because they're just toggling an aimbot
off and on and it's bad it's so bad
so I'm really glad to see that they're
doing stuff to address this I'm glad
that they name-checked all these things
and above all I'm glad that they've also
name-checked the fact that if you're
having someone carry you and you know
they're cheating and you get carried to
flawless by a cheater you will also get
banned cuz yeah screw those people yeah
like I've run into multiple fire teams
who are doing this in comp and it's very
clear because two of them are from a
and they're not cheating and they've got
a dummy account with them that is but
it's just something that happens within
their clan and if your clan does that or
if your group of friends does that you
don't deserve to be playing this game
back you do not deserve it my brain
sorry bridge brass won't reach why you
justify it to me I'm so which on that I
know we got that a little bit junk the
policies you're going where I was gonna
go he's on fire
he's on fire because that's literally
what I saw that policy change I'm like
yes Bunch
this is what I'm talking you guilty by
association if you are in there with
someone who is actively trying to carry
you the whole everyone's getting locked
up I want everybody criminal things
accomplice is still a bad thing to me so
what you locked up because it everybody
shout the Aries in it who ruined my car
that five wins Thank You Aries did too
he was good but it was just so happy to
actually face of where that wasn't
cheating so that was actually cool you
don't say what on yeah like this this is
this is big you know I love that they're
being specific you know obviously they
can't give everything away because they
don't want to give stuff away to the
hackers or stuff they're gonna do you
know I like the working and involvement
with ball valve in reference to other
things you know look they're on it you
know we know the situation in reference
to obviously the pandemic and forest
resource management but one of the
things I know I want to jump ahead a
little bit you know yeah but um I really
liked what they said in reference to
resource shifting because for me I
actually was worried because I'm like
look we understand cheating is rampant
it's horrible right we understand they
are not fully staff from a team resource
like a lot is people obviously working
on be 30 and people they have another IP
matter and that we know that team is
split I affectionately called him the B
team he got his gets back I called it
but who's left working again conventions
but anyway the team that is remaining
right I felt bad because I know they're
not fully stocked and then obviously we
have a parent Amex so they can't come
into the office they can't do the things
that they would normally be able to do
to maybe attack things with a bigger
speed so I I feel that when you're the
integrity of your game is threatened you
had that's dire consequence that is fire
alarm now right so to see this table and
to see them say we're shifting resources
we're doing this we're doing that that
to me gives me a lot of confidence that
they are going to fix this thing that
they are going to save trials you know
especially on PC this is huge this is
huge I don't even want to get into the
rest of the little points because
obviously wife mentioned the guilty by
association thing yeah so like the big
question like some people are saying
it's like the key policy fire teammates
like I mean we covered that it's like if
you were an accomplice I was like and
that's if you go on lfg and you find
people and all of a sudden you see this
doodle responding over and over report
up and leave like they're not gonna get
you for like one game but they're saying
if you go full seven wins all the way
flawless to lighthouse and the students
cheating the entire way yeah you still
watched it happen you didn't do anything
about it so fully agree with that
shifting resources we literally talked
about that last we asked and the last
week last thing is something we
mentioned it could have been that
Thursday when you were in packs and this
is one thing I actually kind of wanted
to get your thoughts on as well byph
because we had talked about this before
yes
when considering we're considering
requiring a much higher player time
investment or some basic aliy we had
mentioned some way to get into it
because they mentioned a quest or some
requirement to get into trials and all
you literally have to do right now is
get to 960 which is you walk up to sate
and be 960 and we have joked before is
like you know is there a four or five
hour quest or is there you know as
they're saying playtime of a hundred
hours late I don't like the play time
100 hours seems fitting because honestly
if you're gonna get into trials and want
to be effective you're gonna need to
spend some time to work on optimize your
loadout and if you want to be effective
like that does put it kind of high but
again also is there like an eight hour
quest of PDP stuff where it's like all
of the the rhetorics that's like a
really long quest line that you have to
go wrong
to unlock trials that one's a bit
lengthy some of those in there a bit
crazy but late and one thing Forex has
been much yeah
but something to where still it's things
that you have to go accomplish that like
the free accounts that people just turn
around and cheat I got a new one I got a
new one doing that type of stuff what do
you think the hundred hours is good or
what would you like to see is your way
to get into trials I mean they're even
saying having the season trials be part
of the season passivation
mm-hmm I think that a combination of all
of those is gonna help and it should be
clarified before I say any of this the
there are still going to be cheetahs no
matter what people do this for money and
when it comes down to it there will
still be security breaches no matter
what happens there will probably be less
of them in the future but people are
always going to find a way and some
people make a business out of that so
they are very heavily invested in making
sure that their stuff still works here's
the thing I think a combination of all
this stuff to play trials makes sense a
question number one who does trials
tailor to you well it's got a tailor to
a core destiny fan it's not completely
endgame but trials should be looked at
in a similar vein to the nightfall
ordeal right you should remember that
the nightfall ordeal works at a variety
of different light levels you have the
very base one right which is just a
standard nightfall at 750 or something
right you then have the 970 version the
one thousand versions the 1,000 330
version which is the Masters and then
the grandmasters now you're tailoring to
every end of the spectrum with that and
this is why night falls are good
grandmaster admittedly has some problems
but this is the kind of thing they need
to look at trials for it is something
that people go when they have developed
their character you know so I think a
hundred hours of play time in an
activity not in orbit makes sense you
know and you need to make sure that
there's only certain activities that
counts for because people still on PC
can just sit in forges and gain a
hundred hours of play time by being afk
so go ahead and you know make that in
strikes or in the crucible I put like a
set number of like kills or enemies or
anything like I don't even I didn't even
think set number of kills or anything I
say you go ahead and you make it hours
played go
that Scott point it's not about it's not
about skill it's about participation
you know I say 100 hours in gambit
crucible or strikes and then go ahead
and say like yeah okay this is fine
maybe through story missions in there -
maybe patrol destinations although
that's a big toss because you can write
potentially just get it people finding
that foreign sport and yeah you know
like it's a question needs to be asked I
think you easily throw raids in there
too because if there are a end of that
hundred hours maybe they've tried
Leviathan maybe they're getting into
some of that stuff maybe they found a
team maybe there LF doing it for the
first time you should count that hundred
hours also do everything else they're
talking about it make it part of the
season pass as some things paid yeah and
make it so that it's a thousand power to
get in because realistically when you
have light enabled in trials you don't
want to go in there at 960 anyway yeah
you want a more even playing field you
want to be a thousand light because you
can bet that anybody who is worth their
salt going into trials every week is
going to by this point be ten ten or ten
or nine bags it's yeah that's just gonna
be the way it is so you have won a
thousand power I feel like it's very
fair to increase that as the season goes
on so maybe having the first week be 960
to get neutrals then 917 next then 980
then 990 then a thousand and it's a
thousand for the rest of the season that
would have made a lot of sense I think
but as time goes on you've got to go
ahead and acknowledge that people need
to be invested in order to get into
trials in the first place yeah like if
people are going to go ahead and do that
and you're trying to attract a play
population the lack of cheaters is going
to be the biggest siren call for people
to come back and the fact that these
strong moves are being made is good I
just hope they haven't been made too
late because there has been it's been
five weeks since the launch of trials
it's been four weeks since the cheater
problem really started to show its ugly
head
you know it's for some people that's
already too late for people who've got
flawless I know that they're barely
touching trials anymore so yeah this was
music to my ears I mean when I saw this
this again something we preached for the
longest you need
that level of investment and requirement
that they be able to play you know we
were all scared right after when I was
that pact right yeah we were just like
when we saw it's free I was like it's a
nice gesture but uh that's not going to
deter these cheaters who are running
around with no fear and literally you
know create a new character a new
account right back in the mix we have to
pull it so even if it means velvet
roping trials a little bit for the
integrity of the game it's worth it
because you want the cleanest experience
is nothing more damaging to a game then
the integrity of your game being copper
where people come in there and they know
they are not getting a fair experience
you have to eliminate that as much as
possible so this is huge this is huge
man III III want to see how they go
about it what they end up deciding on
but all those suggestions you made by
I'm for it whether it be a thousand
light you know whether it be you know
hours played the amount of activities
done you have to show a commitment and
investment to the game before you have
to you have to be worthy you have to be
worthy to be at rouse bed that's where
I'm at with it so well you ready I mean
I think this is all good stuff I think
the biggest thing I've just got a
probably reiterate his wife's thing of
timing
I mean your big worry is like you waited
you wanted this thing coming back you
were completely hyped is it on the
building the lighthouse like it's the
hype and the road and this is honestly I
told you my worry is like the
rose-colored glasses of trials of what
they used to enjoy no it was like is it
gonna come back is it gonna live up to
the glory that they hoped the rewards
unfortunately being lackluster the
cheating just like magnified other
issues with it the tokens kind of being
an odd choice that whole farming vain
like tokens I thought we were getting
rid of those not bringing more in that's
like the way it launched unfortunately
was it's good to have the competitive
nature and if it was in a controlled
environment trial has a really fun mode
but unfortunately with the rewards and
the issues that launched with it is it
going to is it going to need like a
relaunch for another season how are they
going to be like hey by the
we fixed a whole bunch of stuff and
we're back for the people who gave up on
it as you said if they'd got flies
flawless three weeks ago
are they checked out and done I've seen
some people on Twitter being like hey
haven't played in two weeks and somebody
else and I can't remember the names but
they are pretty dominant players like
I'm played in three weeks and I was like
well that doesn't sound good to hear as
well from people who are very
predominant PvP players no I mean I was
just commenting one thing you said in
reference to I think the rewards I think
this was it that summer the UM was the
Auto 600 or something right yeah that's
pretty amazing
astral you know I haven't seen the other
weapons outside of those two the other
stuff I agree I don't think those are
you know people screaming from the
rooftops from the other my person per se
but those two in particular I just got
to stop and it is absolutely amazing so
I do agree with you you know saying
reference to that um we just got to see
I mean I think numbers-wise Ivan used
Charlemagne and why I gotta see what the
numbers are
yes they have been going down it's not
completely there yet but we asked to
also keep in mind that they I think
someone did I don't know who was low
know or someone did a comparison the
numbers are actually higher than what it
was last year now granted EC population
you know what they added another
platform
you got stadia I get that you don't
count it does all I'm saying you guys we
got a cloud service it's a nice
apartment no one's manipulating anything
you know you got to deal with a little
input lag but hey after couple of
matches you get used to it there at
least I know it's a clean run
no I know what you say it I mean we we
shall see but I think I actually don't
think it's too late
I think what they have to act fast are
they I think that yes it's it's on a
steady decline but they have to act back
do mental stop being patty hashtag low
population gaming but state stop being
patty I see you anyway all I was gonna
say is I think they have time to correct
it you know one thing they have stressed
that out some of these things are going
to be short-term fixes what they are
gonna be some things that are gonna take
some time you know it key is gonna be
whether or not know people stay around
I still love the mold I still see people
in there playing the mold but they have
to they have to fix the integrity first
and have to do it quickly so we will see
by next season how much they're able to
implement that's my question I mean in
that like I mean obviously that stuff
will get addressed as we go forward and
we keep waiting on seeing what happens
and everything they say this table was
all about trials cheating they kind of
mentioned that and they said the next
Bungie blog article they are going to
look into discussing pretty deeply the
seasonal model bounties especially as
garden games utilizes them a lot in the
ways they're changing them up for future
seasons I just kind of wanted to get a
quick touch from you by fond how you
have enjoyed seasonal model because
we've had many seasons now coming up on
our eighth one versus expansions and
stuff and we're we're you've just kind
of if you're enjoying like hey this is
that season of Don was a good break and
how you think it's been going just as
they're gonna talk about the seasonal
model what do you what do you think
about it what do you think they can you
know continue to improve so to give a
really quick note on it I think seasons
is better and I think it's better
because we've seen the alternative I
don't ever want to hear a single person
try and justify the curse of a Cyrus was
better than season dawn I want a single
person to try and justify that because
we got the main story out of the way in
the space of two hours whereas we had an
entire season's worth a story that was
fed to us slowly over time that evolved
and was given room to breathe people
quit the game on mass because of the
curse of Osiris season of dawn might
have been slower but it gave the story
room to build you can guarantee that if
war minds events on a similar flip had
been over the space of an entire season
if we had been as slowly working up to
facing off against the soul and Norris
it would have been way better instead we
killed a worm God and his Herald who was
the son of Oryx who'd been
excommunicated in the space of what an
hour and a half like yeah I'm sorry that
it's it doesn't even touch the other
thing in terms of content and in terms
of everything else that comes with it I
think that the simple thing now to
remember is that when you're actually
looking at what we get with seasonal
models there's
lots more flexibility to it like the
expansion's may have added planets yeah
sure whatever but there's not enough
room for that stuff anymore
seasons now have the ability to add
flexible content that can respond within
the space of six months like the
response to everything that people
disliked with regards to season of dawn
will be coming in the next season
you know people disliking certain parts
of things and people to the same point
liking things is going to be reflected
in that next piece of content so yeah
it's people talk about we want
expansions versus and this is the other
thing people are crazy with this when
they try and compare expansions and then
they say why can't they just make more
stuff like taking King and forsaken
things no more than twice like what do
you want them to do you want them to
work to the bone yeah like I was
astounded by the scale of content that
we got in year five right and we got
three raids in a year that's incredible
we've never had that in depth no other
three raids in the space of a year right
like the closest we ever got was year
one of Destiny transitioning to the end
of year one and start of year two right
now and we didn't get anywhere close
right this is a much more sustainable
model it's better in terms of the
delivery for it they need to go ahead
and they still need to iron out problems
I've grown you that but holy Lord it's
so much better than the content droughts
we had back in taking King then we're
long then the terrible like small DLCs
that we had with the sake of curse of a
Cyrus you know like yeah dude but
seasons are better and I understand that
people are gonna look at that and
they're gonna think at first that
seasons awful less content but over the
space of three months it's way better it
is so much better and people who
complain about it to me are crazy or
they have rose-tinted goggles and they
do not remember how bad how bad the
drought I remember I remember how bad
the content wrote was not even from like
taking King to take in spring but how
bad it was just from the dark below
up until house of wool as well like it
was bad the game was dead there was
nothing happening so remember that like
I'm like you know this was truly back in
the dark ages and if people don't
remember that
then holy Lord who really don't
understand how good we have it right now
I'll grow on you this season's worth of
content has been bad like right it has
been bounty simulator on the pv side of
things plus a public event it's been
legendary loss sectors cool ok whatever
guardian games is effectively a bounty
simulator as well this is not great
I've keeping it real now let's see if
Mike was gonna keep it real petit and
trials has not hit well like that it is
a low player populations has ruined
trials but they've made some decisions
with regards to the loop but the
delivery of content and the pace at
which this stuff has been coming out has
meant that there's always something
there week after week and in a season
where that works like say season of
opulence or season of dawn you can see
what the results are the results are
good they are learning slowly but surely
in pollen lessons it's important now for
them to find a good rhythm and to make
sure that each season is packed with
stuff that's not just good quality but
it's also worth players time that's
their big kind of challenge coming up
next so that's all I'd say man like you
know we have it way better with seasons
than we did with everything else they
just need to be able to hit their stride
and actually create good seasonal
content consistently like look back to
season of opulence and what was done
right not just the fact that you know
everybody loves menagerie don't try and
replicate that over and over again but
like what was really treasured about
that season you know it wasn't just the
fact that we had a raid it was the fact
that then we got little things in
between like the Toland mission for bad
juju attribute you know all the slow and
steady hints that there was something
coming around the corner with the moon
you know like these were all really cool
times to be there for in destiny this
has to happen I mean at the end of the
day you know they have to pick you know
they don't have Activision they don't
have Vicarious Visions they don't have
high Moon Studios it's just there so
also this is a live service game
you have to continue to to give content
now we do agree yet season a worthy is
probably the latest it doesn't it may
definitely a lot of things that can't be
corrected but we have the model just
needs to be tweaked with certain things
and I think they seem to be receptive to
that I love in this trial specifically
how they're saying hey this is what
we're doing as far as trials you know
next week we're gonna be transparent
with you as far as the Ward's it's
because I think honestly by I think
that's the biggest issue right now I
think if grandmaster actually rewarded
people for that investment the correct
way if trials besides the cheating um
rewarded people the correct way
if the ever verse store wasn't as
dominant as it was with ornaments
because people think when we said last
last more like that's loop I could you
imagine doing the pit of heresy in
looking like all the armor that we got
from taking King you know the hard
version I want to come out looking like
a hive God like D people don't realize
these ships that they're putting in it
these are things that we used to strive
for and be one it was a sign of you know
respecting and you were just like wow
look at that Guardian and tower he did
XY and Z but everything is it's been
such a shift to ever verse it is just
like oh you just buy that and then when
you do the actual content let's be real
like you know God in a Salvation Army
okay it I'm saying it's a little bit of
a reskin you know so I think they also
have to folk that loot is a big part of
the rubble armor is a big part of the
loop system a part of the reward and
they need to get back to that man
because a completely different yeah if
those things corrected then people would
be grinding these things that they want
us to grind I think I've of us content
should have no relation to whatever's
going on the season and that whatever
you make forever verse you also make
something of equal value in the seasonal
content that is delivered through PvE or
PvP activities right like leaning poof
perfect example of all of this ends up
being say the season past ship
that you Gong in season eight season of
the undying when Shahrukh he gets
launching right that was a perfect
shoo-in for being able to make it drop
in the garden of salvation rate because
it's actually related to the kin top
three and their story is told through
what all of the gear that you get from
the garden of salvation from the
divinity to the armor to the weapons you
know like all of this stuff that we
could have gotten is instead funneled
into the season pass and I think that if
they just make it so that there's an
equality between the cosmetic loot stuff
you can get from ever verse and the
stuff that you can get in game because
basically then it'll be fine because we
already have no actual loot that creates
stat values or anything coming from ever
verse like ghosts arguably sure whatever
but right you know that you won't you
will never get this crazy piece of armor
like an exotic alone from the season
pass right like you'll get your weapons
sure but you can earn that for free
you're never gonna go ahead and pay for
it you can get certain high pieces of
armor from the season pass but there
will be Legendary's and moreso than that
you can also get them to drop randomly
in the season for free like I'll grant
you it's very low chance it's much
easier to get them just through the
season pass but there is a very least
nothing that you will buy in the ever
store like there needs to be the parity
of cosmetics and that way it feels like
there's more to the actual game and you
know maybe maybe that's not possible
like I hate to say it but that is it's a
scary possibility for her yeah you might
need to accept the I know we gotta push
him on that but you know it's like
that's that that's the scary reality of
what it may be what if there isn't
enough money you know like like I agree
I really don't understand how it
functions inside and so in my opinion
it's not valid for this one but I will
just go ahead and I'll just go ahead and
fight the corner for this one thing and
I'll simply say I don't know enough to
say that we couldn't have more core
attics like yeah I genuinely don't know
and it kills me that I don't but yeah we
see the ever verse
of a pretty substantial offering every
month and it is their way as they are
completely independent to support
themselves as kind of an ongoing thing
besides buy your season passes by your
expansions that's their ongoing way it's
like and pricing even at some point is a
whole different discussion we've talked
about before too but I mean I think as
you guys are saying is I sit there and I
run pit of heresy solo working on a flow
and eventually I'll put that thing
together doing like say if you did pit
of pit of heresy solo maybe flawless or
not but as you get did some of those
things some people run that thing like a
hundred times and they do carries so
like you go through pit of heresy and
you start getting a set of armor that
makes you look like so Mac like I would
be break walking around like an absolute
like fire nitrate man in the Tao and
people like where the hell did that come
from like the moments and then our from
rise of iron and I cannot remember what
the end of it was called where the armor
came from those types season of yeah
hhor-- triumphs yes that those armor
sets were beautiful and maybe that type
of indie one could handle a time
management the fidelity has to be there
indeed too but as you say is the
bandwidth there to develop it maybe it's
not everything all the time but some
things you said seasonal related some
specific something to earn in these
large activities like pit of heresy got
like one weapon not armor not not a ship
the this season the ship and the sparrow
both look like they fell in a pit of
heresy yeah they do exotics I'm like why
are bad is that not in there they look I
bought one of them I'm like I don't even
want to change the shader because it
would've been a Piercy
so it was like as I sit there and I'm
like looking at the necropolis and
everything like that I'm like if I could
look any bit like this to show proof
that I went down through here would be
amazing so no I'm with you like they
have to find some way to pay their bills
got to keep the lights on understand
that was really good but on the other
side I feel
yeah the earnable stuff in game is
lacking and it doesn't always have to be
everywhere all the time full vendor
refreshes every season
maybe not but like pick and give us
something to go after over it like if
done should lastly here yeah if the
dungeon lasts a year you
give us a little more love there for
example so that type of thing so I
totally agree for you guys yeah I think
you're on it I've said this ad nauseam
but yeah it'd have to reward that that
level of especially pinnacle acting you
got to be able to show that stuff
completely well that is the end of the
table and we are literally at a mark of
time that I hopefully have respect
hopefully we didn't keep you too long
but it's been probably get back to work
at some point I think we gotta call it
at this point but ya know for sure man
it has been an absolute pleasure and I
think everybody could obviously pluck
your brain for more information
oh I mean we are more than honored to
have had you on here sir it's been a
hundred percent pleasure Lee thank you
from from all of us to celebrate our
hundredth with you I couldn't honestly
pick you much better of a way dream
dreams come true man thank you for
having me
and if you guys are listening over on
Twitch or if you're listening to this
after the fact while it's been uploaded
it goes to youtube I if I'm remembering
correctly yes yep yeah if you are
listening to this in any place go ahead
and give these guys a follow make sure
that you check out that podcast every
week it's uh yeah exciting times in
destiny and if you are following Lord
kognito in a bond test they are also
content creators in their own right so
go ahead and yeah exciting times means a
lot from the legendary Lord you've been
way too kind to me for you for the
longest rows I need you to fight the
announcers for the clinton-era Coliseum
and Final Fantasy 7 because your back
hype that's a classic see I love those
announces at that game I love that see
much appreciative and like I said I said
before we couldn't take you enough 100
episodes no one better to celebrate it
with you know we love this game we all
have a passion for this game you're one
of the pillars in a community so really
cool
and I shout to you again because a lot
of people when I tell people these up
esti doesn't have any story let me
educate you on some things and they they
come around from they say yeah you know
what
maybe budgeting tell it the way maybe
express it the way they need it to be
sometimes but there is depth there
they're great characters compelling
stories this is awesome man so wife
where can the fire people find you me
what you got going on
predominantly speaking YouTube and
Twitter just hit 200,000 over on Twitter
I'll go ahead and follow that random
little bits and things all over the
place so yeah I agree but when dots move
on a wall yeah no calls for everybody to
stop panicking absolutely if if you're
looking for more curated content YouTube
is the place youtube.com slash my name
is byph you can go ahead and find that
there the nice thing about that is I get
to go ahead and make structured videos
and yeah I get to explore the different
worlds of various games with you guys
right now that means destiny and doom at
some point in the future an iframe
backup is a lot of stuff going on
wolfram right now as far as I hear and
then also there's other games here and
there that we cover through that sounds
like a you problem which is where mods
and I basically have fun and excuse my
French would kind of [ __ ] around a
little bit it's late enough it's totally
fine it doesn't count you're good you're
good but ya know if you want to find me
over there
youtube.com slash mine it was byph or
just search my name is by fin the search
bar I feel like I might just beat out my
name is Jeff now I feel like it's good
either I'm not sure anyway you can find
me over there that's where I made them
float or in my content I do not stream
on Twitch anymore just a boy I know just
that way you know yeah if you want to
wrap up yes sir yes like I mean I know
we can get this man off to his world of
things so if you guys know where to find
us like quick ten seconds wrap us up and
then we will send him off yeah
absolutely might get at Lord kognito on
Twitter you already know in our law
podcast YouTube please check us out and
every Sunday is the Lord's Day
1:00 p.m. Eastern we will have rage of
virus on from the Lords of gaming dotnet
man so check that out when you talk
about all the latest consoles everything
that's going on in gaming and of course
the loop of my bro 100 episodes II
super-proud this little passion project
of Oz and it's just cool to see the
growth and again can I think buy any
more for they like tremendously to have
him come through by the campfire just
talking destiny you know that means
always a great thing so so Lou on that
and that's all I got yes and then for me
it's a bond test literally everywhere be
it YouTube Twitter or two inch obviously
if you guys are in here watching live
thank you chad has been amazing very lot
of generosity in here I can't call them
all out right now but thank you guys be
at Twitter and YouTube this has been
amazing and again from from both of us I
know it's like yeah thank you for the
Centennial it was a perfect you know
stone to a hundred so we thank you very
much and at the end of every episode if
you've ever seen fire team Chad it's
probably something similar I always like
kind of do a little numerical wrap-up
and we just say and it has been and all
together by if this will be you as well
we say the last word since the name of
the podcast and that's where I think you
say any Latin if you want but I looked
it up I was like know what it wasn't lag
externa member boodleberrybum or
something like that wasn't but it was
like so thank you guys so much everybody
in chat it has been amazing
we got to let this man get back to his
life so yes this time but for episode
number 100 so cool it's been April 24th
and especially guests here my name is
wife thank you so it has been the last
word